une production du studio sfr bienvenue
au sans fil dans le podcast on parle
qu'avec nos invités date si tu cherches
quentin avec moi d'une plante
si vous voulez nous entendre réfléchir
de la conversation convient d'avoir une
très vite et aller vers notre page
pétulance confère encore moins de
filtres ou est-ce qu'on jam un peu sur
ce qui vient de se passer
donc allez vous abonner là dessus cette
semaine pas de castres en a reçues et pl
cloutier youtuber et instagram heures et
on a eu une conversation super g
descente juste avant on va aller dire un
gros merci à nos commanditaires le
blocage aujourd'hui est présenté par fse
il avale la faculté des sciences de
l'administration de l'université laval à
québec
si vous voulez complémenter des
compétences de gestion sur les chercher
surtout il avait un manque dans les
compétences de gestion
c'est là que vous allez chercher ses
compétences le de toutes sortes de
programmes que vous pouvez faire bac
maîtrise aussi des formations plus
courtes prépare ça à temps partiel ou à
temps plein donc il ya certainement un
programme sur mesure pour vous pour vos
besoins
c'est des programmes et les programmes à
distance qui ont été montées pour être à
distance qui ça fait longtemps que les
c'est un pan t'es belle avant la
pandémie a été testé et perfectionner
quoi d'autre qu'on peut tirer dessus
mais en fait que vous soyez gestionnaire
ok vous soyez mêmes scientifiques ou
entrepreneurs tout le monde d'aider
d'apprentissage en gestion apporte
suggestion de budget gestion personnelle
les ressources humaines tout ça vous
pouvez aller chercher des programmes
pour vous aider j'en ai je vais vous en
donner si le microprogramme en
management pour manager d employer des
gens et 1 microgramme en communication
marketing sur les nouveaux médias se
jetterais en bonne note on en parle
beaucoup des médias sociaux de gamme en
forme marketing sur les nouveaux médias
donc tous ces microbes rehamna et
plusieurs autres sont offerts si vous
voulez avoir une meilleure idée de
comment vous orientez vous pouvez leur
écrire à l'adresse qu'on va mettre dans
la descente podcast qui ont une équipe
chevronnée qui vont savoir vous
accompagner
selon vos besoins fake et vous diriger
en fait par les programmes qui sont bons
pour vous avec mercy fs a eu l'aval
olliet le podcast d'aujourd'hui est
présenté par la science qui est une
entreprise de recherche contractuelle
spécialisée dans les essais cliniques a
été fondée en 9 92
ici au québec lors locaux sont à
montréal qu'est ce qu'ils font en fait
ce qui soutiennent la commercialisation
de médicaments génériques donc des
copies ou des versions moins chères mais
tout aussi efficace des médicaments que
vous connaissez bien qu'ils sont déjà
sur le marché
y participent aussi à mettre sur le
marché des nouveaux médicaments
puis on sait la recherche en science la
recherche clinique c'est super important
snetap essentiel en fait au
développement de nouveaux médicaments
qui ces médicaments la pression on en a
besoin et on que c'est important de
participer il est de soutenir la
recherche
comment ça fonctionne en fait vous allez
aller sur leur site web où les appeler
pour voir l'éventail de tests qui sont
proposés vous choisissez celui qui
conforme à vos intérêts et si vous
répondez aux critères d'admissibilité
vous allez être choisi pour aller passer
un séjour en clinique ou ce que vous
allez faire les tests cliniques vous
avez les repas gratuits
vous avez un dortoir vous avez
l'internet vous avez la télé hd mieux
mieux de mon appart dans le fond à
verdon il ya une indemnisation monétaire
2009 mille dollars par don tout
dépendant de l'étude que vous choisissez
pour avoir plus d'informations
dirigez-vous au triple w points gault
alta point ca ou appelez au 54 3 en 8
052 2 0 merci la gagne d'alto sciences
de commandes c'est un pote est donc pas
un truc pied sur le podcast d'hommes des
cours en a parlé à mes conversations des
conversations qui t'ont qui tarit dans
plusieurs directions parfois plus
légères parfois plus sombre alors non
nous parler d'elle au début on tombe de
raconter une anecdote que tout est bon à
mes impressions parler de la commune
deux sous la ceinture à péage on a parlé
de parler de debra dû pas mal pour ce
qui est des gunners allaient peut-être
être d'accord ou pas d'accord avec une
autre vision de ce
spectacle de ce show sinon on a besoin
de parler ouais on a parlé de la commune
surtout le pl comment qui vit ce qu on
le sent on le sent vulnérable notre pays
elle ne chante pas s'en sortir
georges pop et ça va bien aller c'est ce
qui se passe est fini le beau temps
vient pis on va s'en sortir le palet là
on a surtout parlé de pl dans le temps
des fêtes il ya eu une controverse
autour de pmp allié vital en voyage à
l'automne puis on avale un podcast vous
allez voir être en voyage piètement
qu'on peut aimer ce décret son jeu c'est
pour recommander de l'an voyage qui y
était beaucoup beaucoup crise qui aimait
me a été sur une page ken c'est en
france qu'on revient sur toutes ces
événements le comique et vécu c'est quoi
cette vision de tissot ck une autre
vision de ce habibou débat de société
c'est l'heure de d box honoraires
prudent dans l'air du temps que c'est un
lieu dans son important d'avoir d'une
manière saine d'une manière ouverte
dialogue sans tomber dans les insultes
et se fait que c'était vraiment
intéressant puis merci pl d'avoir abordé
cette discussion avec nous - exact parce
que ce projet qui est évident à aborder
encore moins sur les réseaux sociaux
comme avec le sans fil podcast on ne
veut pas sur les réseaux sociaux puis
puis situation qui est importante à voir
mais qui pas eu ans qui pour que
beaulieu en fait sur le climat en
général des médias sociaux quelque chose
qui chez que doom puis moi nous occupe
assez assez profondément la discussion
du podcast nous permet d'aller dans le
sujet dans toutes ses nuances qui est
excessivement difficile à voir
par écrit sur les réseaux sociaux puis
en est cependant très épaisse de climat
le calme et leur face à face ici en
discutant des humains et bienveillant ou
à l'esprit c'est possible de nuance un
peu plus en sachant aussi qu'on parle de
bonnes places c'est moi et personne qui
veut que l'autre personne tissés entre
que plus des coudes gagne plus de kout
fait que parlant d' écoute
bonne écoute plus de plus de
bienveillance bonne écoute qui je suis
j'ai pas fini
là il trop la plus longue de l'histoire
tp alliance beaucoup de messages
vraiment violente puis paulson et
beaucoup de gens qui reçoivent des
messages vraiment violents d'insultés de
votre part si ce faux s'arrête et pis si
vous participez à ce jeu vous invite à
questionner les motivations qui et pour
quoi de faire ce qui je pense s'amène
rien de bon vraiment dans la société
parce fuck
j'invite tout le monde à se calmer le
pompon points
calmez-vous le pompon calmons nous le
bonbon calmons nous pouvons gagner bonne
écoute
ps mon moteur
[Musique]
le film something about mary les arrêter
j'ai écouté que mario un je-ne-sais-quoi
fouet ça fait longtemps je me rappelle
qu'à ramener ce coin c'est les couilles
dans un sport est simple le film part de
moi c'est ça et je trouvais ce terrible
vous êtes jaloux russe non non vous
j'avais enfin sa médaille des propos
vraiment arriver parce que tu sais pas
je te dis que oui où tout ou ton pénis
le prépuce ça m'est arrivé j'avais eu au
moins deux pays ce qu'ils achetaient
tout petits le peter one piece avec
ernesti de daisy pas vraiment savic qui
était qui est petit est un métal etc les
genres rustique puis le mans j'avais pas
de bébé tendu de ce cépage pas fait
attention je me suis super la graine
j'avais mon prépuce qui sortait du port
puis je m'étais super par le sujet
jamais crié de même je me rappelle poste
j'étais petit j'étais vraiment jeune
mais je me rappelle pas qu'est ce qui
s'était passé après je crois que sa mère
qui est venue prendre l'espace et à fait
ok les bailleurs exigent toujours une
cicatrice à nancy samedi cinq ans ils
n'ont même pas c'est ça c'est je me
rappelle
je me rappelle pas ça va être quoi les
contrecoups ce qui doit se chausse que
je me rappelle c'est vraiment le le
feeling pileux le visuel de ma peau qui
dépasse en mer il faut que tu écoutes
tsonga mais oui parce que ces moments là
la fed se répandant jean 12 min ballon
mais bordel ça finit plus la police
arrive et wazin la ville au complet
vient vérifier que mon nez comme 3 mars
à deux points spi regards sont
aujourd'hui soir ils veulent vendre
c'est rentable mais moins c'est regarder
ce film là parce que je parle à un goût
plus jeune que moi qui à vérone il
s'était fait couper des cheveux pidjot
genre de mersch par rapport au précédent
mais comme son petit gabarit mais il
était plus jeune et 6h pas je dis pauvre
ce thème l'acheter comme pardon piccone
tout cas ce qu'on fait à la régie lui se
sentent change à gorki jodie faut pas
sur une tête avant de tête et fait gris
le noir devant ça va réduire ta libido
les filles vont apprécier sa fille
lorsqu'elle fait ce cafard en salles le
20 mai il comprend pas ou est ce que
c'est un lien ils trouvent bonne je me
suis bien plus marqué au moins un pilote
janvier comme x qui est un apport faut
que j'aille ouvrir en fait que akon tard
lundi a fait l'homme et wii bleue a
quand même salué par ckoi sur ton
oreille gens du gel pour les cheveux
reproduit comme folman a beaucoup je
commence à manquer la semaine d'après un
film très très c'est fou quand c'est
fait mais le sais tu comment c'est fou
ce fameux l'attitude yacé cameron diaz
et ben stiller gens mais bien steria un
rôle mineur ou encore du film ce sont
une espèce dany espions tout croche qui
essaient je me suis qu'il est meilleur
qu'il ya risque ou passera en tout le
temps c'est ça ou d'indicés qui se met
des petits papiers d'en face coince
c'est ça c'est ça le charme de go
transit
visiblement le problème de peau comme mr
vro quelque chose tu développes des
plaques des boutiques et à cause quitte
à cause qui tripent sur elle comme tout
le monde
l'enfant avait tout le monde mais je
comprends moi même mais je trippe sur
mairie est tellement génial
en plus c'est comme un coeur sur la
patte ça 50 points fait de même le
comprendre pourquoi ces gens rient et
quoi et podiatre je peux tu rentreras le
père des pieds qu'elle occupe de son
frère autiste est belle comme tout est
célibataire à tient compagnie à sa
voisine de palier qui est comme une
femme seule dans le besoin en tout en
décochant semble ben stiller et 7
comptait jusqu'à 500 mais ce sera autre
chose sur son nom mais là j'ai pas pu
voir la fin qu'il fallait que je parte
et le j'ai jamais été capable de
retrouver mon modique et est amazon
france 1 qui était sur netflix comment
je vais écouter ce [ __ ] ce genre de
films qui passent à tallinn fac et entre
gpo qu il va falloir que je me tape la
fin bientôt péter cheveux c'est un peu
une coupe canada c'est beau elles sont
sur le déclin gloin j'ai eu comme mon
bruni moment dans le temps des fêtes où
est au mieux les dix empreintes
changement
pour la première fois jean 20 ans des
gars là est aigri gens là ça c'est sûr
bleach il essaya et la chronique coiffe
c'est un pli et ensuite un tonneau tous
ces cols bleus acquis au nez ni défaut
le beau george va leur faire c'est juste
qu'elle est est compliqué d'avoir des
rendez vous est le seul mais je vois que
j'aime ça quand même ça fait jaser les
cheveux on avait les cheveux de même un
peu un peu mieux cet oubli naturelles
dont on aurait tellement sur ces
notations dans le temps on était
tellement tendant piscine que le chlore
décoléré nos cheveux on avait tout les
cheveux blonds man mais en plus des fois
salafin x2 vient faire là ils étaient
d'égalé par bottes étaient des gueules
vraiment le jeu centaines et des
centaines des petites boules de feu
jacques anquetil boule de poussière
major de cheveux entremêlés dans ma tête
des cotes des pics passer par ces jeunes
brosse là dedans c'est un cauchemar
jallet sa coiffeuse pigeât y avait
jamais fait ce qu'il fallait 4 à chablis
j'aï la texture ouais c'est ce qui est
illégal à ce jeu c'est comme une éponge
en fait j'en écoute et vous big brother
les cheveux rouges
c'est sûr que ça m'aurait fait la même
affaire le tir en importe que ces dégâts
la streif et aux cheveux avoir des
cheveux longs tu peux pas faire cela
parce que tu peux pas leur bleach et 20
le teaser mettant veron l'un des bannis
cloutier cje serais curieux de voir la
texture ou autre je me sens ce crime
ça fait genre 30 ans qu'est plus que ces
casques bleus mais avec 15 matches peu
jambe pendant un bout de temps
je ne sais pas c'est quoi le film away
brut
mais comment dire jamais je suis très
partagé
moi j'espère un des drogues fans de big
brother qui regardait tout laisse un
nombre qui est en train de prévoir le
coup d'avant sur chaque joueur
un flotteur comme tout un jargon de
jouarres moi c'est comme j'avais écouté
love story les premiers big brother
faculté comme je replonger là dedans
mais c'est tellement décevant québécois
font semblant de jouer avec brodeur film
mi journée
c'est vrai quand on note que les scènes
qu'il faut pour que ça et on va monter
les missions de cette instance qui
comprend pays personne ne veut vraiment
jouer on dirait un outil dit qu'ils sont
en danger comme pablo juste il ya eu des
chevaux juste moi d'aller dans seront
payants note je me demande si ce n'était
pas prévu d'avancé comme geneviève borne
et pour nos motos à son émission de
radio comme si parce qu'à ça avec son
corps de code c je comprends mais
emmanuel qu'ils aient quitté
son propre grille parce qu'il ya un
contrat qui porte des églises comme pas
le choix ces jeux les plus graves que ça
les gars arrivent le télé réalité
mettant est
c'est sûr que oui sauf que maintenant
c'est moins pire dans une maison à bali
que d'être dans une maison à pouvoir
sortir de chez vous au québec le thé
avec d'autres mondes voudrais citer le
tout le temps c'est doit être long à
tabanac lui mais je pense que c'est
moins long pour lui parce qu'en plus ils
en prennent privilège qui n'ont pas des
petits sillons des livres ils ont du jeu
ils ont leurs médias sociaux comme le
rapport mais oui ce soir lorsque de ce
que j'ai compris je pense qu'ils font
trois jours de captation par semaine en
quatre jours à rien car seuls quatre
jours complets à ne rien et donne le
jeudi je pense l'élimination avec sur ce
qu'il ya plein d'infos qui sont pour eux
c'est la face et qui se passe mais la
frappe le oui il franchit contrainte est
la cause de quelque chose peut laisser
passer ce mais on voit rien au fait que
c'est juste le temps d affaires hors
contexte innelec quoi je comprends pas
le format est trop court c'est comme
c'est vraiment une critique par rapport
à l'émission le sais même pas par
rapport aux joueurs mais il faut pas
faire des dernières des lions le temps
de ranger montre ainsi succès le mont
messi et coûterait tuner est absolument
le havre ac de stocks pour faire un don
via moi je trouve que hendrix et mettons
au d une émission ça va vite se portent
peine à faire passer c'est vraiment
monter série les brodeuses tu dis on
vient de passer cinq minutes là-dessus
genre cinq minutes sur des dix rivalité
mais il manque des affaires métier j'ai
l'impression que normalement c'est une
horde des épisodes avec brodeur à
l'erreur dans le monde
le temps de montrer des relations entre
les candidats
les moments où ils cuisinent ayons pas
de 12 janvier mon pote capte les salles
de bains gentille comme des zones douche
privée mais il ya les lavabos il se
passe plein de choses dans la maison
puis c'est pas juste en changeant de
stratégie comprend les stratégies c'est
en les voyant interagir ensemble qu'on
découvre aussi de philo on dirait qu'en
22e minute quand on lève les pauses by
tout doit rester à peu près de 20
minutes dont quasiment rien de temps de
montrer à part françois qui gère ce vélo
6 + leçon rajoute jean thomas qu'on
enlève victimes
on attend encore les votes c'est ça
finit que ces jeux soient toute la nuit
j'ai des missions en vrac le jeu mais
j'aime écouter avant c'est la fausse
bonne idée et andrekson mais c'est
n'importe quoi
ils rediffuse des moments de la semaine
en version intégrale mais on dirait que
pour pas payer des cachets eu des eaux à
toute la maison ils vont se concentrer
sur quatre
je vois tu vas voir maintenant le défi
du patron mais la captation c'est
jusqu'à 4 joueurs effectuent voit même
paul girot complet l'otan tant les
micros dans ailleurs dans maisons qui
ont petit coupé suit trois conversations
même temps met en voix juste une des
fois ils vont faire un genre fois que
mary king pendant une heure dans la
salle où ils font là où il y mettre
quelques atouts des offres en quatre
cachets pays
mais derrière ce derrière ce style parce
que mettons sais quoi qui pourrait
expliquer les le manque de qualité de
l'émission met pas ce que tu aimais tant
cc nouveau derrière ce we puis nouveau
je dois y ont quand même fait tourner
ont quand même de l'expertisé danseuse
c'est juste parce que c'est pas la même
période
on n'essaie pas les mêmes problèmes et
ceux qui font messmer le respecte et des
spéciaux de messmer qui font des courses
mais elle sait pas du tout la même gang
et c'est maintenant si ça c'est pas la
même équipe pendant toute la fête c'est
sûrement pour cela à gages mais c'est
compliqué aussi ont des bâtons des roues
c'est maintenant la chicane
marie-chantal
c'est comme ils ont rien diffusé parce
que j'imagine qu'il va voir l'équipe
plage ans de marchands tels des avocats
très compliqué versus quand c'est
monsieur madame tout le monde où l'eau
un petit peu plus on peut jouer plus
c'est tout même à audignon sion - pas
d'écorcher le candidat tandis qu'elle
tue ça qui protège l'image de tout le
monde pour faire de la peine à personne
pis au touquet le thillay plus rien dé
médecine de base ce genre pourquoi lyon
qu'amener marie-chantal c'est comme si
on endosse pas ses propos ben ali
n'avait voulu son facebook depuis 2008
gens comme vous que tout le monde que
c'était vraiment donné partir du genre
on est surpris en tout cas on endosse
pour sedan la semaine de la santé
mentale on diffuse pour semer voyant
vous attendre en même temps même temps
c'est le plus vieux truc les de prendre
du monde un petit peu instants après
midi les téléréalités le jeu doit c'est
justement vraiment solide ça serait
moins mais moi je pense qu'une des
preuves un des problèmes ou si c'est si
le casting est ici c'est pas la
brochette de personne la plus
intéressante
regardez à de vision neutre et doit pas
en avoir plusieurs
il doit en avoir plusieurs qui ont dit
non c'est sûr ça m'intéresse faune fax
et souhaite être une maison de plan b
vous mettez chacun qui par tous je pense
que le monde est année je pense que même
s'ils doivent cette année mais m'en bats
les deux se dire ça n'a pas de sens dit
que j'étais ici pourquoi le ouf c'est
juste pour l'argent métier c'est ce que
la prod doivent s'arracher les cheveux
ça peut-être parce que qui essaye
d'écrire des activités crédit agri du
suspense qui a lieu pour une semaine
en plus moi ce que j'aime pas c'est
qu'ils contaminent le jeu sans arrêt il
ramène des nouvelles de l'extérieur
c'est là comme lyon eu des vidéos de
leurs familles
le tout genre la blonde le shom de
camille qui est lors monaco flippent aux
joueurs de devoir était dans une grosse
stratégie pour essayer de manipuler cas
vu son venu bousiller le taux la blonde
de françois où le fils de françois qui
dit jean rey a en tout cas ils ont l'air
de pas voir ta manigances mais voyons
tout le monde je comprends pas et qu'ils
fassent ça puis surtout que c'est
maintenant que ça arrive dans d'autres
éditions qui vont avoir des nouvelles de
l'extérieur mais il faut qu'il a mérité
s'il va voir un défi et si vous gagnez
le défi bleu vous avez les nouvelles à
l'extérieur ou seulement ceux qui
gagnent le top 3 vont avoir leur déficit
faites-le
elles vont avoir leur récompense à caen
- sa nourrice je le sais juste que les
voyages à ce que je comprends pas cette
cette édition du canada pense au mont
houy mais je joue à non moi j'ai pas
embarquer par tous non non non jamais de
la vie
jamais de la vie je serai peut-être
retourner à un mode et j'avais jeté une
hausse si je retournais genre dans un
pays extérieur mais les aliments fermé
genre la seule affaire que je déteste
dudi c'était qu'on n'était pas né dans
des maisons avec d'autres membres que
j'ai pas choisi fait que si tu t'en veux
pas juste parce c'est pendant aussi
longtemps
les jeunes ont quand même l'air le fond
de moi j'aurais vraiment responsable une
autre photo venise où il a passé tout le
monde pour une affaire de banale gagner
toutes les semaines
j'ai juré qu'il faut que tu es seul et
ça pue pire c'est lui qui reste le plus
longtemps avec 6 12 ans a pu s était ce
terme cache ce genre mais c'est surtout
qu il fallait qu en jeu
touche le bouton il y avait même toit
dans le fond ils étaient tous dans une
cage transparente vitré et il fallait
lui tienne le bouton le plus longtemps
possible et ont bombardé la cage avec
des eaux d'argent du purin de lamu fait
n'importe quoi qui pue je vomis est bon
il fallait juste qui touche le bouton
fallait même pas qu'ils payent ce
vacarme qui était juste comme qui sait
bien que de l'os pour qu'ils
maintiennent une pression s'est
effectuée comme les tout les jeux sont
rapidement 10 à la déprime et c'est
quand même moins désagréable weapons
petites habitudes ces gens comme année
ça pue chez vous c'est habite le tout en
apportant la visite cette semaine à 10
heures il ya eu aussi une espèce de
petit aspect on devrait freak show un
peu dégradant le titre mettant devant
s'il ya non seulement deux célébrités
plus tard e-velop chèques des célébrités
première émission son jardin même
jeunesse plateforme précis de rester
accroché que de l'eau d'enfer c'est
comme ça que non mais ça fesse
artistique est dans le vrai avec
broderie aussi des compétitions où la
moitié de la maison va manger du gruau
toute la semaine et les gagnants du défi
rongeant du traiteur 5 étoiles
il ya beaucoup de joueurs de souffrir de
qualité au québec sifflera
c'est quoi la veille ont gagné une
soirée superbe et pourrait coûter de 1
pourquoi qui ont le droit de voir ce qui
se passe à l'extérieur de 12 pourquoi
c'est toute la maison qu'ils gagnent
divisait la dent avec un défi que c'est
juste la moitié qui gagne puis quand il
regarde le super bowl en plus gentiment
gang des ipad ou le quoi qui fait chier
[ __ ] mais choisir les gagnants qui vont
inviter à son petit artiste ou probables
on se fout de la marde c'est lui qu'on
prend pour aller en tout cas vraiment
engagés comme consultants l'année
prochaine dit on passe à côté plein
d'opportunités de faire un bon show si
je souhaite ont-ils et mettons toute la
semaine passée manuellement dans les
jeux mona lee mais montrent le peu qu il
s en aller fenua crois qu'un montage
fait nous passer quelque chose puis
finalement manu seconde est qu'il ya
aussi pas un as du rodin assez longtemps
rome 9 passes et tourné trois jours à
l'avancé
ouais fait que peut-être quelqu'un aura
la charge en otage et assez rapides ces
méthodes ayant trois semaines veh qui
ont trois semaines pour savoir qu'est ce
qui s'est passé savoir l'opinion du
public est rendue ou de savoir qu'est ce
qui peut vous montrer versus l'opinion
du public tf1 qui ont comme vraiment une
longue période pour faire le montage le
quant à trois jours c'est pas top en
temps réel à l'est le public pense c'est
que là dessus
peut-être que tu te lances dans une
pique au final afoc quand ça sort là tu
vois que l'opinion publique est devenue
quelque chose d'autre m pas le choix de
toute vie pourrait faire semblant avec
le montage metacom pas de choix de
montrer ses affaires le comme quand je
travaille à star académie moi j'étais
dans l'équipe de scripteurs le nom de
fonds fait qu on écoute et des caméras
je rêvais d académiciens jusqu'à l'heure
du souper au resto le chef de nuit
commencent et puis il y avait une
chicane qui commençait en deçà rami et
brian puis le show star académie est pas
fait pour c'est pas d'enfant et pau misé
là dessus s'est fait l'écho sur les
vedettes invitées sur leurs preuves en
tant qu'artiste mais une discussion
qu'on avait avec les réalisateurs qui
était là depuis juin de star académie
c'est au choix d'en laisser sortir un
peu parce que ça m'a mené sa tête ce
salon c'est arrivé comme une surprise
pendant le match c'est ça qu'il faut
pour james peur que si jamais ça cendres
ça s'en venait
belga au moins ça arrive comme le public
fait pour ceux qui viennent à se
compliquer puis ils l'ont fait avec brad
aurions voulu masquer l'espèce de
chicanes en barres d'appui et
marie-chantal qui le quinquis tout ça a
pété puisqu'elle marchante elle a décidé
qu'elle ait quitté d'elle-même est en
fait une espèce de go baqrack sont
revenues jean trois jours en arrière
la chronologie suivait puis plus rien
qui marche fx et sept jours de manipuler
vraiment ce qui s'est passé pour vrai
pot donné un show il ya une limite c'est
quand tu sembles écouter quand même pas
mal tu l'écoutés tout les jours tout
débat des mets absolument jaillissent je
serai là jusqu'à ce que commencer j'aime
pas fonctionné donc je comprends que je
ressens je l'écouté si le coupable c'est
tout ce que j'aime le plus de big
brother c'est qu'à cause du concept
n'est jamais question de la les ch'ti de
coded sur ils sortent pas ça ne fait pas
partie des conversations ce texte star
académie malgré tout le mobilier la
copie durant naturel dans la disposition
les invitons des masques des broderies
ça peut pas faire ça fait du bien je vie
par procuration quand je les vois faire
des parties de son propre petit de ce
que la colline jouer dans le moral
salut à mendier jeu toujours pas
d'ailleurs je toujours pas rétabli et
c'est la première fois que j'ai je me
rends à quelque chose depuis le mois
d'octobre mais je sais comment c'est
vraiment mon dernier tournage c'était au
moins d'octobre qui est loin de celle
attendait mieux c'est je suis je pense
qu'on n'a pas fini de mesurer les effets
des pour sûr tout le monde je ne renie
tous breathing même ceux qui disent
qu'ils ne sont pas je les crois pas je
ne connais pas j'écoutais l'émission
code québec avec mc gill ce genre d'ions
sonder le québec c'est léger marketing
qui par des traits de caractère des
québécois puis ça a été filmé l'été
dernier poste était là l'été avant la
pandémie s'est il va falloir qu'ils
refassent le sondage
ça nous ressemble pas il parlait du côté
différentes les québécois elle reste du
canada par rapport aux habitudes de la
nourriture à les québécois aiment
découvrir des trucs nous on mange thar
en inde du monde à la maison on aime ça
les anglais russe et ben on arrive à
manger une demi heure c'est fini c'était
vraiment
léon né on a changé à chaque jour puis
le clash entre communes quand j'écoute
cette émission nous comme qu'est ce
qu'est ce qui va lui même
même à l'intérieur de la pandémie est
vraiment une courbe qui a fluctué le
temps comment on traiter la situation
lundi parce que même au début on a juste
hier à tout le monde en parle mais quand
quelqu'un qui le journaliste qui est
elle allée castonguay - alain castang il
parlait du début de la pandémie puis des
tartelettes portugais comme l'espèce de
soutien collectif mais même moi je te
lances dans ce monde cette loi des
droits mais finalement de son on voit
qu'on est tout le monde ensemble plus la
presse ça c'est comme à stx et l'ontt et
puis c'est dur d'être prêt pour sa part
ça on peut jamais être prêt pour ce que
je pense que je pense qu'on aura pris
beaucoup puissent y en a une autre qui
s'passe baggies comores des moeurs
mécanisme mais il ya juste un mois j'ai
même pas deux
j'ai toutefois deux fils de chien
maintenant plus de certitudes à propos
de rien qu'est ce que tu veux
par rapport à tout je pense que ma
définition de l'avenir plus rien que je
suis incapable de me projeter dans le
futur je sais pas mais il ya une chose
que je suis certain c'est qu'il va y
avoir de plus en plus de pandémie ouais
je sais qu'on sera j'espère serait pas
invité pour remonter le moral à tout le
monde mais je sais qu'on va être confiné
à tout bout de champ dans les prochaines
années parce qu' une des choses en ce
moment c'est on n'a pas confiné assez
vite vos prochains signes on sait
comment faire on sait qu est ce que ça
prend on va être je le vois venir
la population vieillit des virus
meurtrier y en aura de plus suivant
notre chère à prier aussi le voyais
parce que somme toute la cause idée
dangereuse mais le taux de mortalité
reste quand même faible par rapport à
l'ebbo là ou non le vih peut importe
d'autres virus connus qui ont connu des
épidémies
enfin c'est quand même entre - juge je
pense pas qu'on vaccine tout le monde
puisque plus de séquelles chez les
jeunes bressans qu'on est pauvre
est ce que tu penses qu'on
tout envisage pas un retour à la vie
d'avant mettons ben oui dans la vie de
tout temps la vie qu'on vivait avant
sans préoccupation de kovy a oui
absolument moi je pense que c'est lille
à noël prochain
on oublier la cause de l'eau mais ça va
pas être long je pense qu'aussitôt que
les 60 ans et plus sont vaccinés on est
des cons finis et le 11 comme s'il y
avait pas eu de lendemain comme il n'y
avait pas de lendemain on va revivre on
peut le faire la fête on va frencher on
va se coller on va être à osheaga par
dessus l'autre je pense que ça va être
oublié puis la raison pourquoi je pense
se sait que dans la communauté gay on ne
le vih qui est un épée de damoclès sur
la tête de tout le monde depuis des
années et des années et dernièrement
mais dernièrement depuis quelques années
déjà la prep est devenu un peu le vaccin
contre le vih que la communauté gay
s'est rendu tellement mais tellement
répandu qui elle se protège espérant de
vue or par la communauté gay ici je me
dis que la nature humaine même si le
virus la copie de rien à voir avec le
virus du vih qui dans sa méthode de
transmission mais dans les comportements
dans la nature humaine
je pense qu'une fois qu'on sera vacciné
on veut avoir oublié rapidement les
règles de base qui sont à laver les
mains le petit masque cela je m'attends
à ce que ça disparaisse ans le temps de
le dire
possiblement que mon ski arraché d'un
bar pile ça va être vraiment que ça va
être une copie
mais moi je croyais et si seul mais oui
c'est la première occasion qu'ont eu
lieu d'aller voir mettant de la musique
live ans davis en tête comme on faisait
tout le temps mais c'est sûr ça va
arriver le thé volontiers que sa 6e ça
va arriver là tout le coeur de la
pandémie c'est de protéger les personnes
âgées vulnérables et on sait qu'ils
peuvent aussi avoir des personnes plus
jeunes qui ont des complications mais
l'histoire de plus en plus la
statistique moi qui me rend fou je peux
pourquoi qu'il dévoile c'est que 92 %
des décès je pense sont 70 ans et plus
9 0 gêné lorsque j'ai trouvé ça quand
même particulier qu'on dévoile son en
conférence de presse
mais d'après theo ben oui ça ne touche
pas ça qu on fait on espère faire de
cette cyclo avec moi je pense qu'une
fois que nos parents seront vaccinés
c'est pas une génération qui aiment se
faire dire quoi faire je pense qu'en ce
moment il ya beaucoup de gens qui dans
toutes les générations confondues qui
ont envie de faire leur part sur la
pandémie mais c'est d'abord motivés par
leur propre peur d'attraper la co vide
une fois que tu leur enlève ça je suis
curieux de voir l'élan de solidarité va
jusqu'où ça sera très intéressant de
voir mais son vin preview de son âge ça
regarde en floride
bah oui c'est une passe à la campagne de
vaccination et comme vitesse grand v
enfin j'ai l'impression que ça on verra
en même temps de l'autre côté tu es les
espèces de guiry des mesures sanitaires
qui surveille les gens pis qui s'y est
comme une police un peu aussi le fait qu
est-ce que même si gouvernement nous y
rester confiné passe quand est ce qu'on
va être prêt est celui qui défie les
règles au risque de se faire et ça
dépend combien que tu es dans ta guy on
dit que la majorité - tome de l'autre
bord effectivement mais parce que quand
on aura gagné 60 ans et plus je pense
que la majorité se vacciner vdh en
termes démographiques sont tellement
nombreux c'est dans cette tranche le et
c'est la raison pourquoi on confirme de
façon aussi intense en ce moment c'est
kate majorité de la population qui
veulent pas qu'on soit là que j'ai en
tout cas j'ai hâte de voir mais c'est
tellement dur à savoir maintenant est ce
parce que les informations sont
tellement disparates tellement difficile
à atteindre sur l'euroland des vaccins
sur la quantité condamne sur les
possibilités trillard j'ai fait une
story se monterait à d'une tante hodgkin
story pour deux vendu au monde ce que
penser que lors des événements septembre
octobre
parce que je faisais référence sur
marathon le pilote 50% 18 50 % pensent
que non infectés c'est vraiment comme
tout le monde est basé sur les
informations qui leur sont données pi
beyond et les piles plp
50 50 devant qu'une idée c'est très
pervers la façon dont ça se passe parce
que moins du sort - tu as l'impression
que la vie a continué et plus de sorts
plutôt l'impression que personne se
forcent trafic tac
il ya un vrai décalage que je le vois
dans mes amis qui ont des travers des
emplois qui leur permettent de
télétravail et il voit des trucs et on
devait envoyer les gens vont ce qui est
ce à ce propos du mal à des gens qui ont
des enfants quittaient qui travaillent
dans des épiceries heureux le jour à
mais le bon chemin c'est pire on vous
demande continue et désaxé tellement
décalé je pense de nous regarder dans
notre société puis de cannes voir
comment on fait attention piloter coûte
le super bowl puis tu vois les
célébrations d'abris super bowl à tampa
bay petite fée voyons non tabarnak on
est une amine planète parce qu'on vit la
même planète je sais que qui se passe
avec tout cela dit juste su si la
perception comment tout a l'impression
que tout le monde fait des efforts dans
le monde entier tout ce qu'on écoute
qu'on consomme mettons tout ce qui vient
et ce2 une île
tu vois les late show est ce que les
gosses sont chez eux plus les bennes
sont un son sur zoom bidjan le teaser
qui même les états unis aussi font
attention parce que tu vois des
stéroïdes monde sur instagram yamissi
com qu'est-ce que c'est pas juste au
canada et j'ai des amis à vancouver sont
vraiment dans une autre gestion de
pandémie il essayait au livre les jim
son verre départ la vie a repris depuis
des mois là parce que c'est vraiment on
y compterait qu'on est dans ce sens on
voit ce qu'on sait c'est toi à gérer
j'aimais chez moi je suis plus en plus à
boutte jeu plus en plus à bord de tout
seul puis c'est très dur puis c'est très
difficile aussi de
d'émettre des critiques ou des
questionnements par rapport à la gestion
de la pandémie parce qu' une des choses
moi que je trouve dans ce climat social
de médias sociaux de médias de tout
c'est qu'on est de plus en plus noir ou
blanc sec un milieu plus d'espacé sur
des discussions
puis si tu aimais des critiques sur la
pandémie
le vocabulaire identifie comme un idiot
d'inco vidyo the ça vient de nommer
diola qui ont participé aux jo tu es un
idiot parce que tu as des critiques
métal droit on est encore dans un
domaine un monde où on a le droit de se
poser des questions qui peuvent être
acquis monsieur le groupe 6 et puis
c'est pas d'être un anti marc godin
complotistes ces jeux celle des fois de
beloeil un couvre feu
ça fait sept semaines est ce que c'est
encore la bonne chose à faire
on n'est pas en train de dire à quelle
décision mardi on est entraîneur on peut
pas juste tout le temps imposer des
choses puis surtout on n'a pas le droit
de partir les gens qui ont des doutes ou
qui pose des questions alors collant
l'étiquette d' idiots ou de tata
touristes a testé le vocabulaire était
violent comme le dit quand on peut plus
genre d'imagés de l'uqam l'on vote les
plantes corps est-il règlement on a le
droit d'avoir des doutes comme tu dit il
est noir ou blanc permet tout le monde
dans un même panier pythie béton le
conspirationnisme un spectre très large
qui justement typique d'un rebord en
fait c'est même pas la conspiration mais
justement comme tu dis des critiques et
de mettre des doutes sur certaines moi
j'en ai émis des doutes les quinquas man
no tav et les salles de spectacle
d'abord qui fermait milliers d'immigrés
souvent c'est comme si je ne vois pas
les cinémas
non je vais pas dire que c'est une
erreur
de début de pandémie dans même paniqué
quelqu'un qui dirait que le virus est
écrit par un contrôle et j'en ai
rencontré des gens comme ça que non mais
c'est le pouls des populations là on
veut les vacciner maintenant je pense
pas ce qu'ils disent est journaliste à
marjah un tournant par audi tt promet
éric noir blanc puis au sein même de la
santé publique sur des actifs occupés à
santé publique mais dans cette
république c'est dans les experts
il ya des gens qui s'entendent pas il ya
différents et pignons il ya je pense
qu'on aurait pensé comme ce jeu face et
comme ce on ne sait pas la manière
exacte est bonne est sûr à 100% des de
fonctionner il ya un portique on apprend
au fur et à mesure est-ce qu'il jouait
mieux parlement et me semble mais la
sphère qui aurait pu et je me dis au
gouvernement il devrais je suis
tellement rendu cynique on devrait
m'appeler avant de faire les annonces
vont le trouver le bug puis la faire les
cons vos critiques et rend je vais voir
venir tout le temps et ont annoncé on
vaccine le monde au stade olympique que
si ça fait un an qu'on nous dit
rassemblez-vous pauvres et rassemblés au
stade pour les vacciner c'est quoi le
rapport faisceau du phare mais ce
quartier il ya plein d'affaires de même
que tu es content d'être quelqu'un qui
réfléchit place comme je sais qu'on en
sache et on va justement mettez le fait
qu'on soit abutu sidy koné cohérence on
saute plus tôt ce matin des nouvelles
ils disaient les gens arrivent trop d'
avance
êtes vous déjà allé souper chez votre
grand-mère à 4h30 leur peau lié sa table
c'est sûr que ça fait un acte du différé
ni pilote ni 19h30 tonton vaccin avant
être le habitants richard tout le monde
arrive code avance à leur rendez vous
aider à mener vous votre propre chaise
royale
nous croyons veut pas être enfin danse
et au chant
non mais pour m déjà moi je comprends
pas qu'on vaccine au palais des congrès
il ya pas d endroit peut-être un peu ça
tu besoin de tout temps même place si je
veux bien que c'est grand le stade
olympique le mais le corridor pour se
rendre n'y ait pas plus grand parce
qu'une fois rendu ces grandes
tout le monde va passer par la station
pie-ix le dit la petite entrée en rond
losc est le café machin ils vont tout
sera mort ce métier tu millions tu une
ventilation sauf vers l'extérieur ça a
été construit en l1 mais si cette
question parce qu'ils ont honte
on n'a pas la réponse en ce moment je
sais que des gens qui sert apl
il s'est vraiment rentrer incomplète si
cela y est en train de craquer le monde
comme le gouvernement mais non je sais
des questions comble qu'on a le droit de
se poser si je retourne chez nous puis
je suis les règles
j'ai fait une coupe des coupes
d'événements genre de méthode et
spectacles filmés ne ferment
télédiffusion et puis chaque salle de
spectacle on est arrivés le même
protocole qui avait le c'était plus
cling cling cesser c'était un nouveau
masque se lave les mains tout le monde
reste super loin il ya des liqueurs
d'autres la sens lors lever la séance le
les risques je me dis qu'il sur place
les risques d'une jauzion est
pratiquement nulles toutes les
précautions qui ont été pris par tout le
monde
j'imagine que la place où est-ce qu'ils
vaccinent le monde ils doivent être
prêtes à cheval là dessus a ghost qui
que ce soit mais peut-être que s'ils
veulent centralisée ça c'est justement
pour avoir plein contrôle de la la façon
que c'est géré il parce que sim et on se
laisse à tout les uns toutes les
pharmacies
le célèbre à chacune des pharmacies de
respecter de chacun les protocoles plus
de contrôle pas tout le monde que tu
fais tu pour qui les réveille à une
flotte de trois semaines entre le vaccin
et son hifi sa première sont premiers
signes d'efficacité
apprenant problème imaginez attraper la
colline en allant chercher ton bac 500
entrées mais effectivement toi
commencerait en tunique toi toi t'es pas
encore grandi du côté ça
[Rires]
il ya des décisions qui sont prises sur
que tout le monde fait vraiment de son
gros possible avec avec les informations
qu'on a au compte gouttes les nouvelles
affaires qu'on apprend piketty fake
oui je suis persuadé qu'il ya des
erreurs puis-je personae fine tous ceux
ils vont commission genre voyons voici
les erreurs qui ont été commises aussi
pourquoi ils ont été commises mais reste
que des jeux sur ça va prendre une
commission denquête parce que comment ça
se fait que pas d'écrit sur les
recommandations du dr arruda
ça presse à tout prix pour qu'il fait
pas sur un coin de nappe qui ne voyons
donc d'appel à revenu québec sont
enregistrées peut on croire que le sont
en train de gérer c'est sûr qu'il ya des
traces de ce pour quoi on est des bons
il ya plein d'affaires
il y aura une enquête éventuellement
c'est impossible qu'ils aient une fois
que la crise doit être derrière c'est
sûr que ça va être facile d'être
transparent complète c'est parce que
gérer une population c'est aussi un
petit peu contrôlé une population qu'ils
puissent y a pas de contrôle de la
population c'est un peu le chaos et
l'anarchie dans une situation comme
celle-là fake
admettons qu'on apprend dans nos lignes
qu'on te cacher certaines informations
pour éviter que les jeunes faj aurait
fauque date mouvement colis depuis que
tu fasses encore plus des caraïbes des
parties privées ben moi je suis pas
nécessairement compte l'idée de cacher
quelque chose comme scientifique ils
vont être transparents complet quand la
pandémie va être derrière les bressans
que les informations des formations sont
pas sortis après tu es comme ceux cpo ne
sait si dans une optique justement de
protection parce que justement le fait
qu'on soit à accra s'ils ont pu trouver
une info qui vivaldi non mais là c'est
bon sens et qui déjà mais lyon peut dit
on veut pas
dévoiler les informations c'est il n'y a
pas de trace écrite de ces rencontres au
sommet on doit être rendu à pas loin de
800 millions en test juste 100 millions
de dollars dépensant tech de co vide
je pense qu'on est moyens de payer un
quelqu'un qui fait dix minutes le avec
un laptop je pense qu'on serait cassée
il ya des affaires comme ça sûrement
venu après qu'est ce que la lumière au
bout du tunnel est proche tout je
l'attrapé là que commence a été ton
expérience personnelle j'étais dans la
démographie chanceuse sait pour qui les
complications sont plutôt aurore et je
moi ça j'ai eu jean des symptômes dans
le fond moi j'ai commencé à avoir de la
fièvre qui partait pas au bout d'un de
24 heures fait que j'ai décidé d'aller
faire un test et plus on me disait tu
rêves et un test positif de coded
j'ai eu une légère perte de l'odorat et
s'est tous fait du tout après ben ouais
ça devrait même pas quatre jours se voir
leur enfant je me levais le matin
j'avais 100% de naissance mais plus la
journée avançait plus je me rendais
compte que le goût et l'odorat était
moins là mais moi j'ai pas eu la fameuse
tout le quai se pose est un des 5 g plus
haut j'ai pas eu des courbatures mais
vraiment c'est juste parce que quand tu
fais de la fièvre tu dors mal fax et
surtout des courbatures c'est ça que
j'aime et j'ai vraiment pas parce que
j'ai des effets dans ma sentiment qui me
rendent très sec et impatient mais sa
peau est un effet secondaire de
confinement les pressions le cynisme
comme anthony critiques envers le
gouvernement envers les mesures envers
tout il proportionnelle justement à
l'état mental dans lequel on se trouve
le cpie whitney mais moi je touche je
touche du bois
ces sabots et puis le fait qu'on fasse
le podcast je vois des humains
régulièrement face à face interactions
humaines
j'avais peur j'étais que phc on part je
vis une vie presque normale
et puis je suis vraiment chanceuse
tranchant sur pie psychologiquement ça
va quand même bien puis au jour le jour
je pense
pas tellement mes journées à être en
crise puis à critiquer pas faire ça et
j'ai l'impression que prenant que si
j'étais dans une position où est ce que
ça vaut plus mam est impliqué peut-être
mais professionnellement aussi ça allait
plus mal
je me cherche serait probablement un
bouc émissaire le style je chercherai
quelque chose envers quoique analyser ma
frustration c'est normal c'est humain
petit pis c'est sûr si la part des
minutes
c'est la faute un peu la personne ne te
sens arrivent de temps des lycées mais
moi je vais plutôt essayer peut-être
trop tôt pour être philosophique leçon
la pandémie mais je ne trouve un peu
naïf de penser qu'on peut gagner contre
la nature l'analyse moi je le vois comme
un pige pas un complotiste vraiment pas
aux gens je crois pas que ça a été
volontaire ou allez vous mais je pense
que des lap la nature une façon
naturelle de gérer la population puis
les abus picchu et peut-être que l'on
avait un virus et qu'on a tellement
sauver plein plein de gens puissent et
ya pas de bonne réponse à ces questions
le médecin doit sauver énormément de
gens avec des ennuis de santé parce que
par nos progrès en médecine que l'on n'y
trouve peut-être aller loin dans tout ce
qu'on a sauvé l'honneur un virus qui se
payent leur vous êtes allé tellement
loin dans la médecine que l'on est un
doux rappelle qu' on peut pas être
éternel il n'y a pas de bonnes questions
à qu'est ce qu'on devrait faire de
bonnes intentions aux récents avec ça
mais on man et c'est peut-être un signal
c'est sûr qu'une pandémie comme ce qui
est le résultat de deux la croissance
constante de la population et de l'abus
constant de la race humaine sur la
planète fake réchauffement planétaire
élevages d'animaux en captivité dans les
conditions une scène fait que c'est sûr
que peut-être que c'est une façon de
rebalancer maintenant après ce qu'est ce
qu'on fait avec succès c'est pourquoi je
dis qu'il est pas de bonne réponse
si c'est pas nous parler mais je dois
savoir la crise climatique le sait crise
le avoir viré bêta est déjà l'homme
était avant de frapper en pleine face
éventuellement bientôt sans fard match
avoir beaucoup plus marquée sur le titre
c'est sûr on s'en sort pas médecin pour
dire que ça arrive surtout le fait qu'on
soit confiné je pense qui est ici c'est
un peu le mot clé lise mais on a besoin
d'interaction sociale
et puis je pense que le moment de lâcher
son fou
diop à 2 c on attendait des travailleurs
de la santé qui qui font des dépressions
des affaires de même si c'est sûr que le
travail est exempt est difficile mais il
l'a toujours été mais avant il y avait
cette possibilité le vendredi soir de
lâcher son fou d'avoir du vrai bon
plaisir sans culpabilité kg est rendue
impossible
fake c'est sûr qu'à un moment donné tout
ce qui était un peu des trucs que tu es
mais pas dans ta vie d'elliot fall
espèce de balancer de l'autre côté qui
fait bega masse mais on n'est peut-être
pas ce que j'aime à 100% mais le
week-end balança ou les soirées j'ai des
amis j'ai du plaisir avec le tout et
comme rendu à un niveau où et orwell
ming métier mais toi personnellement
j'essaie de me concentrer sur ce que je
peux contrôler puis nombre de coups au
québec puis une nouvelle pique ce type
qui je peux pas contrôler ce qu'ils
regardent et vous beaucoup non je
regarde de moins en moins je regarde
presque plus justement parce que c'est
ce que cela a un effet c'est stressant
c'est si tu sais souvent des mauvaises
nouvelles
j'écoute pour savoir les consignes et
que pour savoir qu'est ce qui est
qu'elles consacrent doit respecter petit
mais sinon je fais du sport j'écoute des
affaires qui est qui qui me font qu'ils
me foutent bien pied
je travaille puis je me concentre
positive tpiy sera facile a dit chris
pas facile à dire sauf que j'ai
l'impression qu'il ya et il faut
vraiment éviter par tous les moyens de
tomber une espèce de spirale de
négativité déjà ça va donc bien mal peu
plus tôt qu'est-ce que je peux faire
pour que moi la personne je me sens
utile
puis le petit effort quotidien qu'on
peut le faire mais la spirale moi
j'étais dedans à 300 milles à l'heure
dans l'automne
même avec les textures le genre j'ai
jamais été un consommateur de protester
j'ai commencé un genre à l'automne là je
buvais d'être 28,1 gg mais pas parce que
j'en voulais c'était par ennui
rien à faire pourquoi pas je vous
m'ouvrir du vin et après ça j'ai une
petite bosse c'est drôle
pourquoi pas un esprit je vous dise
ville de cannabis lui jeter comme partis
là-dessus pendant but mais pourquoi gens
mais c'est juste parce que j'ai rien
d'autre à faire
vous me rien je suis bien jusque là j'ai
eu comme un espèce de crash de mongols
après le temps des fêtes et le g comme
wipe et tout ce qui était médias sociaux
j'écoute plus les nouvelles le matin je
vais pas nier ce genre de soirée le
moins possible j'ai vraiment été dans
des zones pour être le genre j'ai
pendant le début de la pandémie ne
jusqu'à l'automne puis je n'ai pas
écouté un seul film ou rien j'étais
tellement dépassés par l'actualité que
je pourrai pas me concentrer de l'autre
sur un film où c'était trop j'embarque n
ont rien et après il ya eu les élections
américaines j'écoutais ce plu je
devenais comme je voyais les américains
ont fêté dans les ruches de comédie
pourquoi ne coupe pas fait je me
souhaite américain par les frites avec
eux d'un héritier voyaient d'un story
rejeté le dans un état d'un marbre et le
climat dans les médias sociaux est
devenu tellement toxique et l'est encore
aujourd'hui mais il ya eu 1 6 2
le monde tilter pied levé leur faut que
j'arrête fait que j'ai vraiment sera
plug sur toutes mes affaires avec le
temps des fêtes et le gir commencé il ya
quelques semaines a publié mais vraiment
pas de la même façon mais ce compte là
dedans c'est intéressant a parlé quand
même un peu ce qui s'est passé parce que
tu mets ton toi c'est en novembre est
allé en voyage à oui mon voyage cet
automne dans les voyages tout un tas n'a
pas tellement parler mais tu te fais
toujours une vidéo plutôt poser une
photo du feuillage dans le voyage ouais
à un moment où est ce que c'était mitigé
allant voyage mais tête-épaules le
diable en personne ce temps-là voyage
site - qu'il faisait de moi qui t'ai je
pense qu'on devrait peau tout est pas
interdit de ces jeunes ont recommandé
c'était non recommandés et déjà qu'ils
décident de le faire pour diverses
raisons
moi personnellement je dis c'est
évidemment que si je prend en compte la
coved je pense pas que c'est une bonne
idée de voyager est-ce que je juge les
gens qui ont voyagé je connais pas c'est
la personne pour savoir toutes les
raisons pour qu'il voie qui va faire que
ces personnes avaient des sites de
voyagistes qui le krill vos attentions
mais il ya tellement de variables dans
une vie que je peux être à comprendre
quelqu'un irait travailler dans les
hôpitaux le préposé aux bénéficiaires
car est travaillée qui aurait vu la mort
dans le blanc des yeux au jour le jour
et ce type complètement en burn out
total a le droit de prendre sa semaine
si c'est ce qui va la remettre sur pied
a le droit de prendre sa semaine dans le
sud puis jarallah donner à la société
tient si apprend toutes les précautions
et après si tu veux te coller mais en
fait cacher dans la forêt sa langue les
précautions moi c'est que je sais que ça
a été très critiquée en fait ça n'a pas
été critiqué quand j'ai fait mon voyage
cet automne et je n'en ai pas parlé
quand j'étais à destination pour la
simple raison que j'étais quand même en
bon ordre total
je n'avais pas envie de contaminer ce
voyage où c'est un voyage colisée va
rapidement
j'allais à playa del carmen où je vais
trois quatre fois par année depuis des
années dans un herbier nbi que je loue
jeter paulo d'un piscine en train de
faire un parent témoins cancun c'est bon
alors que j'ai fait ce voyage là et j'en
ai parlé au retour parce que je voyais
les publicités de halle en voyage on
fait des rabais télétravail
allez venez passer trois semaines pour
le prix de entre eux il y avait comme un
gros effort pour encourager les gens à
voyager est il ce qu'on mettait de
l'avant beaucoup c'était les mesures
sanitaires dans les hôtels on roule à 30
% à nos employés suite du protocole
strict bon moi je me suis dit je veux
être honnête comme je le suis toujours
sur mes médias sociaux je vends une
vidéo pour dire comment j'ai vécu mon
expérience et surtout dire aux gens
faites attention si vous décidez d'y
aller sachez que peut-être que dans
votre hôtel ya des protocoles qui sont
suivis à la lettre mais moi j'étais pas
dans les hôtels et j'ai vu des employés
des discounters etc il y en a partout
il y en octobre et il y en a dans les
hautes herbes et c'est comme si tu
travailles ici dans une épicerie où
c'est surveillé pic le week end tu fais
des parts et puis que manet que ça a
donné qu'il ya des protocoles ça va le
ramener à l'épicerie ton ta crevé
pendant huit ans et étaient bien dit oui
moi je veux pas dans les tout inclus tu
vois la toile bienne be tu vas plage le
jour tout retourne le mais en fait non
moi j'ai suivi gelé montré dans la vidéo
genre j'ai suivi les réglementations
locales et les réglementations locales
ne n'ont pas l'épidémie de covile comme
nous on la connaît et quand je parte il
faut se rappeler qu'au mois de novembre
mais on n'était pas dans les 2500 qods
autour des facs l' on était dans un
autre contexte fait qu en arrivant là
bas c'est évidemment je pas stupide le
gpo et commencé à tricher pied j'ai
quand même fait plein de choses mais les
bords son vrai je suis allé dans les
bars les restaurants sauvage suis allé
au restaurant la boys ont pour le nombre
de cas ils sont présentement en zone
jaune et ont connu un épisode dont
orange après les faillites
ils sont retombés en jambes la situation
est sous contrôle
est ce que j'aurais fait la même chose
en allant chez pas moins
ouais à québec c'est la différence par
exemple c'est que tout pas dessus d'une
zone rouge
ouais de plus de probabilités que toi tu
le portes pictures l'amène labo où sa
voix je pense que j'aurais été beaucoup
plus prudent si je n'avais pas eu la
copie un mois parce qu'il y avait
toujours cette fenêtre d'immunité qui
maintenant il reconnu ce moment juste
comme pas vraiment dit est le même en ce
moment si tu veux te faire vacciner je
ne peux pas si tu as eu un diagnostic
positif dans les trois derniers mois
donc on reconnaît cette immunité là on
est même en train de réfléchir à ce
qu'on a besoin de deux doses
si on a déjà connu la coded un test
positif de colis de facchetti moi c'est
sûr j'ai fait moins attention que
j'aurais fait parce que d'un côté
l'ayant pas eu je sais que j'étais
immunisé à ce moment là mais ceux qui
l'ont réattaquer il ya quelques cas dans
le monde des gens qui ont reçu
l'accolade toujours moins graves
un deuxième épisode qu'un premier
factice jr un petit peu en mode la tête
libre et j'ai été témoin du père et de
son meilleur lot il ya plein de choses
qu'on fait bien au mexique je prenne pas
parler du mexique faut que je parle la
région du kantô narus que c'est des
études comme on s'est aussi c'est très
indépendant d'un endroit à l'autre
il ya vraiment des mesures qui sont en
place dont le port du masque qui est
beaucoup plus strict là bas qu'ici
moi j'ai tombera au parc lafontaine en
fin de semaine une personne dans son
masque on edouard team
oui mais on est tous on le voit respect
là on est tous un peu
mettez donc vaumas ça peut tuer des
tutsis grave que ce soit m masque mettez
vos masques par éteignez zip on va
pouvoir aller danser cet été
mais entre que oui ça a été critiquée
voyage le témoin je me dis j'aurais
peut-être dû être mal vu pour en parler
tout simplement puis revenir faire comme
si j'étais jamais allé on sait poppy
thorel doigt parce que c'est pas devoir
d'étaler sa vie sur réseaux sociaux pour
un objet de facile non mais honnêtement
quand j'ai publié cette vidéo le jeune
suisse
qu'est ce que je fais toujours de 30 ans
que non plus quand je les fais nettement
ça a été très bien reçu les abonnés des
comores merci c'est intéressant c'est
que plus tard dans le fond ce qui est
vraiment la raison pourquoi je me dis
j'aurais vraiment fait mieux ne pas en
parler c'est que ce compte des noms sont
des voyageurs
et là je suis devenu le poster boy de ce
méchant voyageurs influenceurs avec
quelqu'un d'autre ou sommes critiqués
pour mon voyage que j'avais fait cet
automne avec des yeux de 2500 cours du
mois de janvier est factice c'est sûr
que le gtm année j'ai juste fermer les
commentaires sur mes 10 ans que je me
faisais envoyer chier aux deux heures
j'étais comme boulot j'étais vraiment
besoin de sous et le pour moi la
décision a été facile à prendre j'ai
fait
oubliez moi là c'est plus le temps de
parler sur les médias sociaux il ya trop
de mots si la négative c'est avec ton
exemple précis puis que puisse imaginer
comment malgré toi que ma pensée
vraiment
basculer par rapport à aux climats des
médias sociaux puis par ça fait
longtemps la dernière fois qu'on s'est
parlé
quel enfant tenue sur le podcast est
maître du monde à partir chez nous puis
on n'avait aucune idée de ce qu'ils
allaient s'en venir sur les réseaux
sociaux depuis la dernière fois qu'on
s'est parlé il ya eu la vague de
dénonciations sur les réseaux sociaux
est ce qu'il ya des gens qu'on connaît
c'est tout le monde qui sont tombés
après ça s'est dit lui justement de leur
matrice matin aussi ou est ce qu elle s
était temps parle pas tt tintin ennemis
pilot sais tu en parles tu pars tu en
parles mal plus il ya encore une fois
pas de position à prendre
la presse a eu le voyage justement où
est ce qu'il est dit le pti le premier
ministre fait une conférence de presse
en disant la deuxième vague ça s'est
passé dans les foyers des québécois
puisse laisser penser d'un foyer des
québécois en russie c'est ma tante qui
est allé voir mon oncle jean qui qui qui
en voulait pas de mal à personne
puisqu'elle y sont parce que c'est la
faute de personne mais la faute de tout
le monde en même temps bien aussi de
leur retombe en mode jeu le droit de
poser questions au gouvernement
pourquoi est-ce qu'on a changé deux des
trois fois sur le temps des fêtes et il
me 46 milliards sur une vraie tiges de à
moins que vraiment le pas cet avis à
regarder les nouvelles tout est très
bien comprendre c'était quoi qui n'est
permis
mais la majorité des gens là ils sont
pas entraînés louis fréchette la presse
évite fois par jour même s'il affiche
persuadé que pleinement qui ont juste
accepter de voir quelqu'un c'est pas ma
part c'était permis non mais non mais
c'est pas permis par le temps des
faitelles mais on avait droit c'en était
une personne seule de s'intégrer le gym
feeling que ce qui s'est passé c'est que
le monde donc en fait assez le temps des
forêts de pythie c'est la faute de tout
le monde moi j'ai pas respectueux et
respecté beaucoup les mesures pas à 100%
de tout le temps si c'est comme ça
puis le l'idée était avec la
dénonciation des gens qui faisaient des
qui voyagent et l'espèce des envies de
mettre le fardeau de quelqu'un
puis on était on était chez nous puis on
est gay
page quand selon les influenceurs devenu
de dénonciation et de montereau et il y
avait la faute aux toits en speedo qui
comme une plage merde c'est mon geste
est juste il demandait rien à personne
puis le le sais moi c'est là que j'ai
fait comme okello
c'est toxique en clis c'était vraiment
ce que parce que pelletier asti que tout
ça crisse de vie la seule affaire qui
voulaient forcer divertir les gens
gratuitement sur le web un des premiers
à la force si si impopulaire après on
peut les influencer toute l'ailé mais
youtube heures que vous suivez
maintenant le gars il ya fait son show
king possible dans son appart à moriat
le seul pendant cela que je dis pas glac
au vide il voit une semaine dans celui
semaine pile à l'offroad réel quand
c'est le cas c'est leur faudrait qu'on
arrête je suis mon chemin je récupère de
sa tribune ces camelots tabarnak
mais moi je suis dans les moins graves
là on
pierre arcand qui a été démis d'émotion
il ya des députés qui ont être gêné
qu'on va regarder ça avec le recul
l'espèce de folie pitié puisse vraiment
dans deux mois on entend des opinions
des gens qui se trouve que c'est une
mauvaise idée
mon opinion personnelle c'est quand même
moi j'aurais pas voyagé mais tendance
est sociologue mais de commencer à
pointer du doigt le monde qu'ils font
honte de dire il devrait tout perdre
mais ce n'est pas ça la question on peut
ne pas être d'accord avec le fait de
voyager et aussi ne pas être d'accord
greffer des cas c'est les gens qui
voyagent ça pis encore une fois le
problème et pas provenue de l'opi les
critiques ils étaient les gens qui
critiquent les gens qui sont les
premiers à insulter envoyer des messages
à des encans c'est lui justement au
dessus et respecter les règles à la
lettre ce qui mène à rien c'est juste
des critiques et comme ce parce que john
saison et des petits pommiers commence
pas je sais pas ôté je trouve ça
vraiment hypocrite en fait est de
commencer afin là justement cette police
l'aide des réseaux sociaux des gens qui
voyagent
quand kate moss vraiment surpris juste
parce que ça faisait gens comme un mois
que j'étais revenu cgt comme je suis
dénoncé métier c'est contre la
dénonciation j'ai quand même perdu 1
contre cause de la sinne parce que lyon
fait dans le pea l'iran d'où un peu
controversé on va prendre quelqu'un qui
l'est moins fait qu'on soit pour ou
contre
quand même voir si oui évidemment puis
la pandémie sais c'est que on peut juger
on peut juger maintenant les décisions
du gouvernement qui ont pris en avril de
l'an passé à la lumière de ce qu'on sait
aujourd'hui sur la pandémie
ça ou sur les nouvelles informations ou
sur le comment qui commencent à évoluer
tous sortis le toi tu voyages un moment
où est ce que l'opinion publique sur le
voyage qui combattit c'est qu'à ce
moment leur moi j'ai voyagé je voyage
avec un ami qui est agent de bord qui
est évidemment perdu son emploi
à ce moment là c'était vraiment perçu
des gens qu'on pouvait même voyager
parce que les gens disaient encore
aujourd'hui les gens pensent que la
frontière est fermée
elle n'est pas fermée on ne peut pas
aller en voiture mais la frontière ce
qui est une absurdité en soi mais là la
frontière aérienne a toujours été
ouverte elle est encore ouverte
aujourd'hui bon quelques différences
près au niveau de l' on demande un test
antigénique sur la colline pour aller
aux états unis ce qui était même paul qu
avant you gens d'origine
fatiha comme mais encore on peut ici
demain matin j'irai à la punta cana très
facile à prendre un vol de delta et vos
parts des trois tilleuls va réussir ses
ports fermés en ce moment ce ne l'est
pas essayer toujours pas illégal c'est
toujours examinées mais c'est vrai que
quand moi je suis parti avait pas du
tout et je les dis à ce moment mais
sûrement que je leur ai dit arrêt parce
que c'est pas mon genre mais si ce match
com et les comptes de dénonciation pour
c'est la préciosité juste pour la
pression d'arrêt dans la mode d'antan
des fêtes pileux avec justement lire et
qui ont mis sur ses épaules droites et
de voir sa famille dans temps des fêtes
puis juste pas besoin de nombre de coups
après c'est encore une fois les gens
étaient tannés légende est frustré les
gens étaient au dessus puis qu'est ce
que ça fait
et on cherche un bouc émissaire abstiens
toi mais du projet en disant j'ai pas
parlé aux autres
j'ai vraiment déconnecté je vous dis
l'heure comme ça ça a commencé
maintenant le 30 décembre
ce fameux conte avec les pitchounes
pilot et
ça a comme dès le départ dans une bonne
semaine à un moment donné j'ai arrêté de
développer un genre de co2 d'or le jeune
quelqu'un qui me ville des vulgarités du
monde
c'est à peine si j'avais pas été
égorgées leurs enfants de la nation qui
m'écrivait le pij et développer une
espèce de stress avec des notifications
gevrey instagram cinq ans je veux même
pas les voir fait que j'ai jusqu'à
enlever instagram pendant une couple de
semaines de mons elle passe à générer de
l'anxiété sur des affaires que jeter
comme un chat tout fait du bien pour
répondre puis c'est une revue des
articles des sites web qui m'aiment pas
ou qui vont tout aller chercher un petit
tatouage je préfère comme faux j'ai
toujours la même politique gens je ne
nourris peau ces choses le fait quand
même rang tu ne réponds pas absolument
je ne vais jamais répondre à ces
affaires là c'est la seule façon de
donner de la vélocité à ces tribunes là
qui se nourrissent de contredire ces six
mois je rajoute mon grain de sel fait
que j'en aurai je sais pas qu'est ce que
je veux pas me défendre garde
aujourd'hui on en jalles je peux dépit
mais j'y réponde un commentaire répond
non ça je fais juste serait prolongé cet
épisode puis justement parlant de
prolongement c'était comme le
prolongement aussi de l'indignation sur
instagram qui a commencé avec les
racismes qui est une cause subregis
insee piqué qui dit s'être stx qui qui
se passe après ceux sur les agressions
sexuelles cause su prologis cnt après ça
dans la manière dont ça se fait sans
doute clairement pas optimale ce qu'il y
avait un ménage nécessaire à faire sans
doute aussi la pression n'est resté dans
certains modes d'indignation le plan
c'est chercher des causes le après ce ce
sens est devenue une mais l'a précédée
c'est comme si on était espèces des sur
le même pied d'égalité ou dead avec
l'homme la main mais même esprit juger
de ces affaires lui qui ne sont pas du
tout mais pas du tout sur un même pied
d'égalité
même au delà de mettre deux différents
sujets sur un pied d'égalité même à
l'intérieur c'est ça le prend avec les
réseaux sociaux c'est que même à
l'intérieur d'un mouvement tout le monde
et toutes les actions sont à égalité
une action qui mérite d'être dénoncé et
pareil pour toutes les actions le titre
fait qu'un quelqu'un qui connaît un viol
quelqu'un qui te dit c'est la même
action mais qu'on cancer descoings
quelqu un qu une entreprise qui fait de
l'argent
nouaille face à puta leur aurait fait de
l'argent vous serez impliqué tout sur
tout mais ça c'est les médias sociaux
parce que je suis certain que dans la
vraie vie les gens sont pas comme
ceux-là l'homme c'est sa fille que peu
importe ton opinion de ton petit sujet
toi qui est hong kong bol ça va trouver
suffisamment de monde que rossi fait
leurs combos numéro un pour te sentir
que c'est le combat de tous mais sa
séance mitigé comme dany turcotte la
queue remis son cette mission s'est
posée le mot entre saint gilles un mec
dubaï j'ai arrêté de schiste fini tout
le monde en parle et je comprends
tellement le genre à mon ma toute petite
échelle j'y ai goûté un petit peu je
peux juste imaginer ça doit être quoi
quant à cette tribune là mais tu ne peux
pas attendre qu'une personnalité
publique incarne 100% des petites
conviction personnelle de tout le monde
sur l'ensemble d'une carrière non ce
n'est pas possible d'avoir cette
exigence le envers des personnalités des
personnalités publiques
tous domaines confondus ac c'est sûr que
ça m'a mené la presse à des sites qui
est fâché contre quelqu'un avant tout à
trouver le temps tout le monde a quelque
chose qui va déranger un petit groupe
suffisamment bruyant pour que ça c'est
comme sans fin et j'ai trouvé entre que
manger en ce moment je n'ai toujours pas
réglé mais je trouve que les médias
sociaux
si on est tellement isolés en ce moment
on est tellement chacun de notre bord
que notre vision de la société nous
provient des médias sociaux à presque
100 % ou avec un petit peu de télé ou
ton voisin qui croise en côte d'or et
c'est sur notre contact sur l'extérieur
tellement que moi j'ai eu un gros moment
dans le mode janvier où je me dis mais
j'ai donc plus rapport dans le québec
gens à quel point je suis différent de
ce que je me reconnaissais dans n'en
rien et jantes crêpage de chignon je
sais comment on dit que ça me ressemble
postaux pis ça c'est sa mère sans péché
comme neige tombait rendu impertinent
dans notre société jusqu'à temps que
chasse basse à ce propos que j'ai pas
accès à toute la société
les internats c'est ça la force et driss
c'est pas c'est encore la minorité du
monde qui ont qui sont sur instagram
mettons au québec c'est une minorité des
québécois qui sont sur instagram qui ont
l'application fait que c'est sûr que ce
bal c'est à ta vision du monde sur ce
silwan est exact que l'on est tous ceux
qui militent après activement
s'intégrant dans des vidéos cité du
mérite et les outils 17 heures parce
qu'on a pas le comme je disais tantôt le
vendredi soir où on prend 20 que nos
amis pour voir finalement il ya encore
de bons moments mais j'ai vraiment une
période de jeu tout comme ben était que
cgt comme je regrette
josé admis mes amis que leurs parents
ont fui leur pays pour s'installer au
québec pour leur demander comment ils
ont su que c'était le temps fait deux
ont fait nos valises on change pas je
m'étais peut-être que celle où je me
sentais 10 connu mais là je suis encore
un putsch mais combien d'entre eux
voient mettons c'est parce que le têt
tenté un retour aux études dans nissan
et orienter sa carrière
mais comment est-ce que tu entrevoit le
futur ton futur agv ton futur dans les
médias sociaux parce que parce que moi
moi je suis en train de me dire foule de
liszt ou parce que dernièrement ça fait
un groupe d'amis du second drop laden a
pas un qui est vraiment active ses
réseaux sociaux le ou du moins qui y ont
un compte poursuivre leur blonde qui est
moins mettons l'été mais il reste encore
10 puis ça fait deux fois que j'ai un
jour mais que d'autre part c'est la fête
d'un dégât puis ils iront pas si conson
que moi j ils ont leur exposer les
arrière-gardes ils ont juste pas puis
vivre leur vie et et puis je me dis
tabarnak que je suis mais ce serait un
grand pas bien hier j'étais au volant de
ma voiture puis avait des gaules et josé
sont un coin de rue péri hier chacun
conteneurs corps du monde qui
rist est comme un corps n y ont pas tout
le monde la face et d'enterrement et
encore un monde qui ont le sourire houle
c'est moi qui délire mais c'est vrai que
et puis c'est pas normal de mettre
autant exposés à tout mais surtout au pb
on n'a pas joué parce que du bon mais
les machines sont construites pour nous
renvoyer ce qui divise ce qui est
consensuelle
on le voit pour après la huitième
personne que tu tag te dois de plus
destiné niaiseries de qu'on est capable
mais il ya vraiment un jeu c'est pas ça
ça serait comme ça ouais moi je peu près
un an je déconnais des médias sociaux
est-ce que c'était sa dernière derrière
l'idée de te dire je me réoriente parce
que c'était juste a hélas c'est un trop
plein de ce jeu puis capable de vivre là
dedans ou c'était juste et quoi je
t'écoute derrière c'est un mélange de
plein de choses qui portent du fait que
moi j'ai plusieurs intérêts dont les
communications les médias de solidité
j'ai quand même ce côté là artistique en
moins qui aime donner un spectacle axé
je pense que j'ai ça mais j'ai aussi
plein d'autres intérêts plus aux médias
tels que ce serait le temps dans le
devoir vers autre chose mais réellement
g il ya deux affaires 1 j'étais
complètement
j'étais très sincère dans mon retour aux
études en faisant merci de m'avoir suivi
jean on se reverra peut-être jamais pas
grave parce que je n'en voulais plus de
genre en vidéo au monde arrêtez de me
suivre
ça me tente plus j'ai vu plus vos
commentaires je veux plus voler que je
veux plus votre opinion sur la sorte de
lien que je mets dans mon café le matin
genre si j'ai découvert ce plaisir-là
l'été dernier de faire des petites
choses pour moi l'argent puisque j'ai
fait c'est toute cette négativité de ces
problèmes-là qui viennent avec le le le
fait d'occuper des médias sociaux de
l'espace public je n'en veux plus je
veux la paix je veux que vous n'oubliez
je veux plus être pl critique jean
mais l'idée c'est parce que toi ayant
fait ça depuis longtemps
moi j'ai pas l'impression que donnait
son opinion sur quelque chose sur la vie
des autres était quelque chose de
répandue avant moi qui étais tu peux
curieusement sur me trompe mais moi j'ai
l'impression qu'à 20 tu voyais un
influenceur ou un créateur de contenu ou
appelons les comme on veut qui faisait
quelque chose tu donnais pas ton opinion
tu le suivaient système est excellent et
très sous le radar il n'y avait pas
toute cette attention là qu'ils ont
maintenant mais surtout y avait pas d
trois matches nuls c'est qu'ils font
leur et c'est sur le sujet de leur
chaîne mettra en lumière des tout à fait
qu'on est pauvre possible regardez les
squelettes dans le placard de pl
cloutier que j'expose aussi il y avait
plus urgent la classe est sûr que ces
gens n'aient de temps en temps la o2
money and shine qui va faire un bep loin
puis maintenant mais il y en a eu une
couple est généralement une forte hausse
monde le métier ils font des vidéos en
mode à 26 il n'y avait pas ce côté là
mais ce moment c'est vraiment l'espèce
des derniers que moi qui me donnait
envie de m'arrêter facteurs allant au
bout du rouleau
je dois je commencer au bout de deux
mois je sais comme je peux pas croire je
retourne au cégep le club en virtuel oui
en plus je roulais des yeux le ca comme
le programme c'est vraiment bien sorte
de seconde mais le j'ai 34 ans j'ai eu
une attaque
j'ai 12 ans 15 ans d'expérience en
travail autonome le j'avais des points
sur mes travaux de session si j'avais
même bien mis les numéros dans le bas
des pages j'ai comme niaiser vous
écoutons programme mais je l'ait pas dit
parce que j'ai il m'a dit que je veux
quoi le finir un jour j'ai pas envie de
mettre d'attentes par rapport à ça tu
vois ça c'est moi qui a changé avant je
leur ai dit le jeu en mode garde une
petite gêne puis c'est plate mais ça a
comme toutes soldées médias sociaux ça
fait ça chez moi ça m'a donné envie de
me crée pas une distance en moins pile
monde qui me suis dit j'ai encore ce
côté de moi qui
qui acquiesce par les jambes je regarde
mon sociaux de l'aigle qui est des
journées je perds 20 h 30 à bonus comme
tout n'est pas perdu plus j'ai pour
stopper la fin pour les jeunes s'en
aille qu'il me faut clac et je veux plus
l'opinion dit non j'ai pas besoin de te
brûle dans ma vie j'en juge
j'ai toujours fait les affaires sans
prétention sur les médias sociaux
c'est comme si on me donne on veut me
donner une responsabilité que je me suis
jamais donné je peux tout le citoyen
parfait je vois toujours des places mais
tout sentir en 2020 un switch dans la
manière que le monde consomme les
influenceurs et christique les
influenceurs parce que mettons jusqu'en
2012 j'imagine que ça devrait être moins
violents que ceux respectueux mais dans
les jambes est autre chose
moi même je n'avais pas le temps d'aller
lire les commentaires sur de tva
nouvelles de gier
qu'est ce que le monde en pensant l'art
c'est comme souvent qu'on décide comment
gérer la pandémie la pandémie le pignon
fait que je regarde les commentaires le
tout grain plus factice d'une escalade
mais non c'est qu'au début de youtou
maîtrise ça donne quasiment rien de
parler des débuts de youtube ça vient de
repos comme quelque chose qui évolue le
stand sait j'aurai boom attaché à un
souvenir de 2016 ou astel von braun
je fais ma tournée de spectacles sorte
sign on rit on a que du plaisir
on fait des séries après j'en fais 301e
voir où j'en ça me donne rien de comme
avoir ces plates ça arrive plus genre
moi je suis content d'eux que tout se
soit arrivé l'otc sont en ce moment je
me choquerait pas contre la météo je
sais de l'énergie gaspillée chaque lot
c'est sur le climat moi ça me convient
pas je reviendrai éventuellement s'il
faut mais c'est dessus c'est quoi le
profil les personnes qui tu écrives
mettons des insultes ou qui des
commentaires ou quittant peau ci dessus
mon jeu j'aimerais ça pouvoir les
identifié comme ça mais non mais si tu
es marié commandes et ce tous les ultras
au cou c'est l'ultra collonges cellule
rosso qui me suivait peau avant de
découvrir que j'étais controversé reste
pas des abonnés qui m'exprime
connaissent mais il y en a plein qui
vient de m'insulter puis m'appelle poche
comme ça même pas seulement au même
poste je faisais de mon taxi dans mes
commentaires il ya dans les mots ce
propos de jean et le spi pas tomber spam
les gens les gens vient de m'insulter
comme c'était moi c'est pas mes abonnés
qui m'insultent je pense que de résumer
la bonne a gelé déçoit pas c'est le
monde qui me suivent pas tu le découvres
ans le maire de laval audition sur plc
qui se paient au jeu l'aï le maire de
laval maudit qui n'était pas feinte
c'est sale affaire c'est qu'il ya
tellement tisha je crois je crois droit
qu'ont eu de ski ski puis de dire son
opinion sur les choses puis de
l'expliquer pourquoi d'une manière
décente qui dit je pense qu'on devrait
avoir le droit d'être en désaccord dans
société
c'est correct imams qui est signer sa
sortie premièrement long de la meuse a
créé des accords c'est comme si tu en
désaccord quelqu'un automatiquement aux
saillies notamment le déposer mais aussi
dit qu'une opinion sur quelqu'un qui
formule 1 même si bien formulé deux
comme une espèce de mars deux mondes qui
réfléchissent peau il rend du monde qui
réfléchissent pour une réaction comme un
réflexe la page six la page quand c'est
l'influencé de cet âge là c'est la pire
chose jamais vue ses gendres aurait une
page administré par quelqu'un qui fait
des fautes piketty kaki qui tire partout
sans trop réfléchir
pis il ya du monde quand quand même la
légitimité à cette les vacances à se
piquer vu qu'une page anonyme de gris
qui fait des fautes dit quelque chose
ça doit il doit avoir raison puis je voi
dans ce sens que je vais envoyer des
excuses il exactement les mêmes mots si
quand on sait à quel point ce point une
idée propre
bonne réflexion propre à toi que tu as
de beaux interdire par des comptes quoi
penser sur qui paie commande faut
vraiment je sais à tomber sur le sujet
qui les anime
c'est ça se peut aussi que c'était le
sujet au delà du sujet j'ai vraiment
l'impression qu'au lieu du sujet c'est
une jungle les gens qui aiment le jam
qui sont embarqués dans cette affaire le
du monde qui qui qui carbure à celle du
monde qui ont aimé ça mais tant la vague
de dénonciations puis le lait mais moi
je moi je pense qu'il y en a qui se sont
sentis qui ont senti qui est entré dans
une communauté qui ont senti une
appartenance à un mouvement puis après
ça c'était comme de ckoi la nouvelle en
fait c'est quoi le nouveau mouvement
qu'on s'indigne puis qu'on critique des
gens puis moi je pense que c'est une
minorité de monde mais cocon assez soudé
qui ont embarqué dans ceux qui
embarquent dans ce genre d'affaires le
mais selon moi ça me dérange pas ces
genres comme par exemple j'ai parlé de
mer de lavage
si vous parlez de moins gens comme
honnêtement moi c'est pour un chemin
créatif qui m'allume je ne parle pas des
autres jamais clair dans l'épreuve des
gens qui ont fait des grosses carrière
un clairement lui qu'un philosophe
quelqu'un il ya pensé au moins dix fois
mais dans le sens où je veux jamais en
vouloir de où j'en ai dit tu devrais pas
faire ça ou essayer de faire take down
ça chez nous c'est moi ce qui m'énerve
c'est quand les gens viennent sur mes
plates formes insulté feliz sûreté
plateforme sur tes propres tribune fait
quelque chose puis nourrit la
conversation ok mais bien pour
m'insulter en dm pour après tout choquée
parce que je t'ai pas répondu profond ou
pire la fois où je réponds ou à des
vosges vue screenshots il a vu mon
commentaire d'insulter une arrière
répondu qu'elle a regardé si je serais
pas un peu importe le screenshot evil
partager je suis pas cave le ca fait
c'est un jeu des médias sociaux les
pièges le g voit venir le coup de coude
avant ce facteur
par exemple une fille qui pendant
l'épisode de sa mère des voyageurs qui
est venu m'en envoyer chier avec des
mots extrêmement vulgaire
me répond pas montignac des insultes je
commençais qui se fait là ça vaut pour
jean je vois les veaux sont cons parce
que je la trouvais tellement intense et
enragé j'ai comme fois je mette une
phase sur ce genre je vais voir son
combat maintenant à l'air comme une
personne très ordinaire aux belges
continuent de ne pas me répondre mais
mes mains je m'abonne arrière je sois je
m'abonne à 100 quand on tue vraiment un
petit art hogan continue est après ce
pompier seuls chez eux pendant mouche
comme caisse et se jeter un peu bavard
or le mali liking qui regardent même pas
les photos georges laraque et pour pop
et dance et notifications ab l'eau de
javel droit parce que lui c'est mon job
il en avait le droit dans la tlpe est à
penser que je peux en train de dire en
larguant ces affaires soient pas loin
d'en acheter pris en défaut j'ai même
pas regarder ces fautes voyez comme max
et le monde secret tout seul ce rien
ouais c'est ça la fin c'est ça le
problème que le mien dit ces lâchetés le
monde ça crève sont rien face à ces
expériences mais des plaques en rien
d'autre à fond mais ces plaques quand et
de l'autre côté puis que tu reçois ça
parce que les gens pensent qu'ils sont
investis d'une mission et se sentent
complètement justifiée et louable de
force mené leur cheval de bataille mais
savent pas que de l'autre côté on passe
sous le sahara en charente charente
charente charente puis sam année on peut
pas non plus on peut pas convaincre tout
le monde en parle mais non mais non
imagine comme en occident son couple
phil et je souhaite que cela en étant le
je souhaite que ça se passe bien fica
réalise que ça sert à rien aux gens non
merci steam et où on utilisait connu
quelqu'un que tu y mets ton info roger
comtois pts essaie de régler la
situation mais peu importe ce que tu dis
à vous être plus fort chez comtois de
bonne foi de la situation toute excuse
mieux comme si rien n'est pas ce que tu
dis même si c'était bien intentionnés
puisque la bonne chose ça va ça va
empirer la situation
ceux-ci genre des fois en coupe ça
arrive mais genre ça
farinelli sociaux c'est comme je demande
des excuses
je m'excuse aubin la ja ne rajouter mais
s'est développée je comprends vraiment
ta réflexion de jeu comme et roche
débattue mais c'est encore trop moi je
suis pas prêt à me c'est trop un
mouvement un paquetage pour autant
m'éloigner d'un courant de la société
qu'est cette chance qui va se passer
avec ce ben moi je pense qu'il ya
beaucoup de gens m'ont stany dessous
yamani les gens vont faire l eau
s'appuie d'ailleurs aussi combien de
gens gaspillent leur retraite à les
chicanes et dans un commentaire de tva
nouvelles c'est ce soit un bel va très
vite mais tout je pense qu'il a tort ce
que ça va se calmer mais je pense déjà à
mon niveau j'ai l'impression que c'est
le début de quelque chose
moi j'ai l'impression qu'on vient de
rentrer dans quelque chose qui va être
vraiment plus long plus vraiment plus
peiné la prise de conscience qu'on a je
pense qu'on sera pas les seuls je pense
qu'on n'est pas les seuls aussi tu
penses que ce cadre un dire le myspace
de ras-le-bol dessous de cette espèce de
climat là je dis non par la team et on
gagne on ne parlait de moi on en parlait
presque chaque semaine le ya une espèce
de ce segment con qu'on aborde sous
l'effet du choc thème anodine il servait
un ici même défendu là dessus quand il
servait c'est vraiment rond avec un
petit pas mais ça c'est le genre de job
que je paie pas ses factures
si tu t'enflammes à cause de ce joker
t'as rien compris le pense que ces
délits comme tu disais tantôt type
danilo qui est appuyée de peut-être plus
la personne la plus pertinente à tout le
monde en parle mais tabarnak
le gars il menait un combo pour la
communauté gay à toutes les semaines à
tout le monde en parlait en parler
c'était ce sont son combat on peut tu as
t'il laisser tranquille parce qu'il fait
une joke un petit peu mal avisé sur un
report le team est un tueur sache aucun
je dis non merci
mais moi c'est le mécanisme d'ablynx
tendance est soulevée l'ironie c'est
tout ça va plusieurs missions tellement
innocent l'attaqué là dessus je trouve
ça tellement de l'attaqué là dessus se
teignent en longueur il fait d'autres
jaffer bonne pour la vie peu on peut
vous demander à quelqu'un d'être de tous
les combats d'avoir tout l'été à chaque
fois que tu dis quelque chose de
t'assurer que aucune communauté ou
aucune personne soit affecté par tout ce
qui étudiant avec l'aval c'est que ça
finit plus je me suis un vagabond puis
je le crois profondément
puis ça m'a pas fait un pli s'approche
puisqu'on ce dommage qu'après ce soir
les vegans vienne condamné non s'ils
gagnent de mauron vont condamner ces
français ou des gens que c'est l'heure
c'est leur mission de vie et que le ion
six écoles à faire s'est il y avait un
article dans le devoir là dessus je sais
ce josé blanchet entre je me rappelle
poster qui met à parler de justement
comme quand on s'offusque pour tout tout
tout tout tout mais a cité en exemple
l'une de ses amies qui avait fait une
photo dr la marche au bord du fleuve
s'apprenait parce que c'est une activité
permis en pandémie
pire les gens qui disaient mais quel
manque de respect pour les gens en
fauteuil roulant qui ne peuvent pas
marcher
et là est ce parce que ça se faisait
critiqué d'avoir micro agressé des
diabétiques en partageant une recette de
gâteau au citron sur facebook joseph
facal
c'était de françois pérusse le sens là
je vous enverrai la chronique là mais
c'était probablement aussi à le prix des
pires exemples on est jetés comme louis
voit loin
photo dans des marches l'ancien qui
exploite le monde peut monter des là
puis je suis de tout coeur avec ce
qu'ils peuvent
c'est ça et puis on serait content qu'un
ascenseur partout oui mais c'est de
chercher des poux on a trouvé tout le
temps mais oui tu es mais lorsque je me
suis pas encore décidée je reviens tu je
reviens pas je vraiment aider si je sais
pas non plus j'étais encore envie de
passer comme un peu de tri qui de pour
pouvoir faire des contenus qui sont
vraiment excitant j'ai besoin d'avoir ce
financement pour avoir des financements
j'ai besoin des annonceurs pour avoir
des annonceurs j'ai besoin d'avoir un
discours qui plaît aux annonceurs qui
est pas toujours celui que moi je
voudrais bien ça m'éloigne de mon but de
faire du contenu qui me tente le plus
factuel qu'il faudrait vraiment qu'ils
aient un mur moins que les annonceurs
comme ces cinq plein de vie des médias
qui existe pas c est dans ce qu'on fait
face parce que justement ce big thing
d'influencé que tu vas directement avec
la personne parce que la personne
représente parce que si tu payes mais
dont une pub au 98,5 et que tu t'en
colle c'est qu'il annonce l'animateur de
cette oui tu peux annoncer des chais pas
moins des jeux pour moi d'aider des
rabais à l'épicerie puis la nouvelle
d'après c'est que le pdg de la chaîne
d'épicerie et dans le trot pia ne le
point annonce pour sa femme assure t
elle un vrai décor c'est qui mais est ce
que tu penses que si mais ton talent
terre poteau contenu que tu fais
vraiment 100% ce que tout le goût de
faire sans souci de quoi que ce soit
tombe plus de difficultés à trouver un
enfant absolument parce que c'est quoi
ce que met-on c'est quoi ce contenu le
tombé jusqu'à aujourd'hui j'ai critiqué
les mesures du gouvernement
comme beaucoup remis de cette vague de
dénonciations que j'avais fait une
campagne par rapport au port du masque
ont probablement que parce que ce que je
viens d'ouvrir ici au début du podcast
j'en aurai plus de campagne avec le
gouvernement c'est ça vole wind est très
très très méchante années de jouer ce
jeu l'aude
j'ai l'impression que c'est créer un
décor au centre - des abonnés justement
parce que j'essayais sauver les sources
de revenus qui me permettait de faire
des contenus ambitieux tels que des
contenus ambitieux you put de l'espace
pour ce serait ce que tu puisses de
sujets car techniquement ambitieux
est-ce que d'une piste de solution au 21
août était juste en questionnement 100%
dans le nez en ce moment je suis
incapable de me projeter comme je vais
une tortue toujours juste et il bat même
ce printemps ouais je suis pas capable
en ce moment de prendre des décisions
toute cette ce climat de mardi dans les
médias sociaux
moi ça alors pour effet de paralyser je
n'ai pas envie de prendre l'espace quand
ça brasse autant et on dans blacklight
demandeurs genre homo critique et ne pas
avoir dit des choses comme critique même
plus parce que je dis des choses s'est
rendu le niveau on m'a critiqué le
connaître des gens condamnés pour des
gestes de dénonciation le match
les la vague de dénonciations des gens
qui connaissent mais avec beaucoup de
recul dans le sens où je me tiens pas au
quotidien avec les vedettes genre j'ai
mes amis sont pas connues je suis paulo
desjouis julien en a plusieurs qui ont
été mis aux hommes de sport tas puis
j'ai beaucoup de tristesse pour tout le
monde là dedans s'est pris un poids puis
je les dis dans une des vidéos c'est la
personne que je connaissais le plus et
que je connais encore d'ailleurs c'est
kevin le doc de papa qui a été parmi
ceux qui ont été complètement
dénoncer et qu'on voit plus je le dis
encore il peut m'appeler
c'est vrai on discute et je suis pas ce
genre le mois condamner des amitiés ou
de cdd supprimer des gens de ma vie
parce qu'il ya des enfants avec lesquels
je peux d'accord genre jeumont pas rire
en prison j'ai récemment le voir je
suppose comme ce genre de jeu
chaque jour c'est une opinion et
populaire les potagers six mois je me
souviens en fait qu'il y avait fait un
poste d' excuses ou du moins de décès
ce puits tout avait commenté parce que
tu savais très bien que c'est de la
bullshit
ah oui parce que les y avait vraiment
c'est flou je peux je peux pas dire que
j'ai comme c'est pas mon sujet que
j'aime le plus le jeu par les revoir ces
trucs là depuis l'été mais je me
rappelle qu'ils avaient dit des trucs
comme si c'est arrivé une histoire
anecdotique mais de ça ce qu'on
entendait des histoires de l'histoire
mais c'est comme s'ils avaient une
attitude doit selon moi c'était même
projet pour lequel il met en modestie
kevin doit d'être le genre comme ce
propos vrai pas vrai tu peux pas dire
c'est juste une histoire parce que là
c'était plein plein plein d'histoires
fait que des gens partent ans a commencé
sur une affaire jeté comme un stick
récemment comme un projet tetris pour
lui d'abord et puis de la main pour les
gens ce qu'ils avaient des choses à
dénoncer mais je ne peux pas fait un bon
moment pour essayer de mettre les
pendules à l'heure où peut-être pour
marca en partant sur un rendement très
vite et puis malgré ce jeu j'ai pu
critiquer quelqu'un picard mayme être le
pour elles ces personnes le besoin de
toi tu as besoin de parler à quelqu'un
qui sait si pau c'est comme si mais ce
système en plus en plus difficile quand
tu connais la personne autiste et si
jamais si jamais noir ou blanc dans la
vie rien aucune situation
jeannette qui sait ce que l'oeil est
carrément des problèmes purement
personnel prime des problèmes des choses
qui a réglé toutes choses car comprendre
puis le bus et qui lui a été fatale aux
autres qu'ils arrêtent de faire du tort
à lui même aussi piqué tous à haïti qui
s'est pas en extraction cette personne
le piège suis réellement intéressé s'il
veut m'appeler je veux savoir qu'est ce
que changer qu'est ce que je peux tu
faire quelque chose et pour la vie même
chose au groupe personne qui dénonce est
bonne je suis ouvert à discuter mais moi
j'ai pas le genre d'homme à dire bloqué
parce qu'elle en fait ce qu'est ce qui
arrive est la raison pourquoi je parle
de ça c'est que que les gens me reproche
tout et son contraire c'est qu'on me
reprochait de ne pas la voir débarquer
des gens les scruter qui je suivais mal
je commets jetons soit très loin de ses
huit photos plus loin on est en train de
faire le bonheur des qui que je suis à
huy à qui je suis lui il faut pour que
je suis la personne
les excuses de gêner la croma temps oui
j'ai lu ses excuses
est ce que est ce que maintenant
l'intention est honnête
est ce que tout ce qui était qu'il
devient vraiment du cas où est ce qui
est écrit par une femme des pilleurs
tout ce je ne sais pas tu es je dire si
les excuses sont vraiment en être si un
cheminement où il y en a pas eu
je peux pas le vérifier je sais pas j ja
saihi posté ce qui lui fait qu'amener
voter quand même des excuses bien
formulé legault semble avoir une prise
de conscience puis faire un cheminement
pitié j'ai là qu'est la publication de
cette publication c'est pas un geste
c'est pas un style disponibles citoyens
geste politique
c'était juste comme le golf était juste
dans les petits cons de titres voix qui
calcule les dix personnes seppi il y
avait du monde là-dedans féminin est
l'outil cavell à iquique laquelle
publication pour ce petit du monde que
je respecte petit monde du cinéma si
critique de type 2
de ce genre de chose le fait que j'étais
tout seul à voir l'équipe liaison mois
qui a connu peu connue du monde qui n'a
qu'à les frais ça grimpe beaucoup actif
le tipi chevaux tejpal des positions ici
parce qu'on gens d'église - mais c'est
rare que je fais des poses de position
sur instagram changer ce jeu des beaux
jamais sur instagram fact et je
distinguais diniz rina team c'est
vraiment rare mais les demandes qui
commentent mes photos genre pourquoi
encourager les agressant c'est comme
n'est pas si simple que ça c'est très
différent s'il ya eu a pu apprécier il
ya eu un gros bang la chaussée excuses
pigeât je suis retourné voir sa
silhouette en like des pauvres et oui
tout le monde que j'ai que je m'étais
dit ah ouais ce genre cette personne ne
tique et militante féministe avait
l'acquis alors laissons lights et puis
plusieurs le tir ça paraissait mal
d'encourager sursis c'est comme un baron
soir même et c'est peut-être aussi que
tend à enlever ton like pas parce que tu
ton feeling avait changé sur la
publication c'est juste que tu donnes
tes potes en mode off choisir ses combos
ligne que je les encourage à pau dit que
je l'inviterai si ce n'est pas dit que
c'est mon ami ça veut dire quoi que ce
soit c'est comme continue ton
cheminement que si tu étais la
télévision sur l'inviterai c'est quand
même beaucoup d'émissions a qui sont
tout à la mode on défend des fins mais
si ça peut attirer du but et marc pierre
moreno santa qu'avaya ligne à tout le
monde en parle c'est si ça c'était sur
les médias sociaux aux mondieux quand
vous avez pas le droit d'inviter ces
gens là il ya vraiment un double
un standard ce qu'est ce qu'on accepte
des médias nepad et les nouvelles
plateformes dites leur cycle art puis on
dirait qu on dirait que l'idée de sens
car c'est me devient de plus en plus la
meilleure option
t en grèce on dirait que c'est seulement
parce que parce que sinon tu donne trop
d'importance à ali minorité bruyante
puis moi mettons il ya cinq ans
l'histoire avec isabelle rioux puis
brett mccormick est sorti le team
o'brian je le connaissais on s'était
déjà rencontré ce pas un ami le mais je
le connaissais le suivi sur instagram
puis après ce jeu les justes me suis
juste pas des abonnés une et et puis le
jeu me faisait écrire à moelle qui est
fille que j'étais genre là la pire
personne parce que je le suive encore
puis le je me disais en même temps je
veux un peu voir c'est quoi cette
démarche à lui passe clairement était
pas bien il n'était pas bien dans son
corps dans sa peau dans ces relations
que les kits photo être plus je me
disais hoymille 1 si je suis qui
s'écoule et ckoi lu marx en voici le
monde vont dire c'est un petit ami puis
le plus je me suis dit faute disent
georges pas laisser les trois personnes
qui m'ont écrit un intervenir dans ma
réflexion alors que je mettais déjà posé
la question que j'arrête arriver à un
consensus de dire je veux savoir qu'est
ce qui se passe parce que c'est parce
qu'il ya quelque chose qui se passe le
qui m'intéresse pas d'un point de vue
pas intéressé à connaître le plus le
même intérêt à suivre le dossier puis à
savoir qu'est ce qui se passe puis je
vois pas laisser quelqu'un deux
personnes trois personnes sur cent
quinze mille venir me dire quoi faire
déjà fait bloquer non non lorsque j'ai
découvert au moins que j'ai je peux pas
croire que j'avais jamais remarqué ce
futur ou instagram
pendant mon voyage gates jeu quand j'ai
décidé de recommencer à publier jeu tout
comme ben qu'est ce que je fais pour pas
que ça parte parce que le gibier ma
profession publication que je mets dans
le film devient une fenêtre pour aller
et crée de la marde
je savais ce en le faisant fac l'heure
j'ai découvert quatre heures devant le
filtrer des mots mais tu peux aussi
coché que tu ne peux pas commenter à
moins d'être abonnés ce qui aura un bon
et un bon effet de filtre de la pensée
que je suis quelqu'un qui l'encouragent
mais le fricktal et il persiste des
abonnés pour que je ne pourrais pas
savoir mais ça quand même
sachez que moi je peux pas croire que
mais on est métisse par rapport aux
faits les gens m'ont scruter le tout
suivi de tirs les gens aiment beaucoup
prêté des intentions vraiment qu'ils
sont paul au départ ayant une grosse
confusion par rapport aux influenceurs
ou whatever sait on parle d'un sujet il
ya une partie du public qui reçoit ça
comme on en fait la promotion
peu importe le genre si je suis chez pas
moins comme par exemple mon voyage et
fait la promotion de voyager je dis pas
je fais pour la promotion
je m'en confesse le reçois comme ça mais
je m'en vais je prendre un des rallyes
there is a lie si c'est ça c'est par la
promotion d'outils pour vous parce que
je trouve qu'il ya des fois il ya une
petite confusion des deux sauts puis moi
je suis très inquiet
ça donne quoi comme artiste tout ce
genre parce que ya encore un côté de moi
qui a la base je pense je m'identifie
comme un artiste c'est là le point de
départ de ma chaîne youtube
c'est un geste artistique c'était parce
que la télé ça arrivait pas j'ai fait
des sketches je fais des personnages des
vidéos du mot j'ai fait des vidéos où
c'est plus des dégagements comme un
humoriste
pour moi ça c'est de la création
artistique et moi quand je pense
création artistique ça vient avec un
prise de risque et le s'ils ont à chaque
fois que quelqu'un prend un risque on le
dénonce ça demain à qualcomm créativité
ou gèrent ce geste artistique
pour le futur je reçois très inquiétants
parce que moi je trouve que ça fait
partie du rôle des artistes de déranger
c'est pas pour être consensuel un
artiste exposé en avoir confié ses
genres la robe en steak de gorge est à
amener tellement de réflexion se
retreindre thank you go go genre comme
et on veut pas que quelqu'un qui aura
envie de faire une affaire comme ça sera
un autre sujet ah non mais je peux pas
le faire parce que le ressort on peut
plus rien j'en sais moi je vais jamais
dans la mesure où ces faits comme c'est
parfait comme quelqu'un graves
illégalités je vois pas condamner un
artiste qui a pris un risque quand même
si je suis pas d'accord avec son idée ou
songe c'est sur ces seuils d'urgence et
sa ford
oui mais à plus touati qui fait
justement des vidéos où ton but stressé
divertir c'est de faire sourire si
c'était c'était pas la gaule liligo
vidéo pour la réserve
mais c'est devenu controversé mais on
était dans la part des dirigeants tout
ce qu'ils voulaient pas le christ est
coupé de la glu que tous vraiment chaud
vraiment vraiment chaud pilule sec
quintiq que c'était le temps qu'il vous
faire de mal à personne
genre vivent certaines pistes en page
près de dix minutes et parce que je
coupais de la glu c'est correct les
droits les gens ont droit à la date d
d'accord pas mais je n'ai jamais senti
comme une personne contre devenu est ce
que tu vois encore faire ce genre de
contenu le jeu demande connue les j'ai
connu funk contenu jusque très justement
dit des trucs nice le début que bien que
touche au fait que votre confort site
s'appuiera pas en 2021
mais je ne sais pas si je me vois encore
le fameux j'ai encore envie de le faire
mais la raison pourquoi je ne sais pas
si je me vois le refaire c'est que j'ai
l'impression qu'en ce moment on n'a pas
le droit d'avoir plus d'une couleur qui
tourne présence médiatique on est soit
avec des sujets sérieux où on est
vraiment une mauvaise c'est clair pour
tout le monde c'est des niaiseries où on
est un politicien c'est le mélange genre
le mélange des genres est rendue
difficile que j'ai l'impression qu'on
est content nefac si j'ai envie de faire
une vidéo de plus puis qu'on n'y a ici
que j'ai un couteau brûlante que c'est
un revival de masse line piqué la vidéo
d'après ge par 2,5 singh que la santé
mentale peut être fragile
on dirait que le à valiant est suivie la
semaine passée comme axe et à new york
on dirait que c'est rendu très difficile
c'est comme j'adore les groupes les uns
de ses trucs il faut être capable
d'accepter que les gens peuvent être
plus qu'une chose oui on peut être
quelqu'un de la main sur le coeur est
tout le temps là pour aider les autres
qui le soir on a dit fier de ses stades
ou bazot c'est à ce genre je sais pas et
compact et elle est en train de dire que
j'ai traité
mais hors s'aspergeant reconnaît un
éventail de goûts et des choses je sais
pas contradictoire on est dans nine
multiples genres non et on peut être
plus qu'une chose eh oui absolument mais
tu penses tu qu'un français le 21 on est
obligé d'être ou book en guinée mais moi
je sais j'avoue je me suis tenu loin de
tout ce que je sais que ça comme le
sujet depuis noël le box mathieu
bock-côté de génie rien consulter de
tout sauf d'un sujet qui m'ennuie mais
j'ai c'est vrai mais elle était si on
n'avait pas de position sur deux peuples
et entre quels mots les mots utilisés
mais juste de prendre position sur 10
des anges sur des causes
je trouve très bien que ça de prendre
position d'avoir des opinions seulement
pas de problème avec ça mais est-ce
qu'on est obligé le thé dansant ce s qui
est ce qu'il ya de la place pour les
gens qui lui font pas ces questions
j'avais mon sens oui il ya tellement de
sujets dont je n'ai pas d'opinion à fait
j'en ai des opinions mais je les trouve
assez pertinente des genres et je sais
pas - le choix de ciment pour ont refait
les trottoirs sur ma rue mais bon moi je
préfèrerais un style qu'un autre mais à
quel point ces impertinents mon opinion
là toujours dit je connais pinceaux et
trottoirs bagages enneigement le soir
j'ai beau avoir une opinion le jeu dans
plusieurs sujets par exemple parce que
c'est vrai que c'est pas parce qu'on a
une opinion qu'on est obligé de le dire
mais ok pertinents aux gens n'y a pas de
sujet que jeune étudiant puis que ça
donne c'est parce qu'il faut le portant
à vos pas la même chose marek les
opinions les opinions se valent mais tu
aimais tant pour venir la tire ou sujet
de la team et ont justement j'avais des
petits j'avais une opinion sur dany
turcotte et avant et après qui prennent
sa démission j'avais une opinion une
opinion sur tout le métier
lesquels ses opinions là valent la peine
que j'aille l'écrire pour que tout le
monde puisse le lire sur les réseaux
sociaux le prépuce est placé que moi je
trouve que c'est toujours c'est toujours
très incarnée c 'est toujours en vert
contre c'est contre quelqu'un impôts
genre à proposer on dirait qu'on veut
c'est ce côté là moi qui m'a chartistes
en wallon
moi je veux exprimer ma pression si
c'est comment l'exprimer
si tu es jeune il ya eu plainte d
rappelé comme dans les derniers mois et
s'étaient rendus comme une erreur
tellement je peux vous savez c'est qui
ce nom
une momie blogueur gens là étaient
rendus de dénoncer parce qu'elle avait
parlé bas et à des gens dès lors qu'ils
que jamais par les bêtes à quelqu'un
c'est non mais ça c'est que c'était un
geste qui a fait tout le temps tout le
temps tout le temps fuit sauf qu'on n'a
pas eu l'histoire au complet tout ce
qu'on a compris c'est que des fois elle
avait été battre avec des stagiaires ou
je sais pas trop
là le faire mais ça et puis le temps est
peut-être venu le dg s'est paumé chez
que pendant le bon bout parce que qu'ils
veulent sortie on a commencé je pense
les loubards de ma génération de façon
très anodines et l'on s'est mis le doigt
dans quelque chose qui vaille c'est ça
qui est quand même un gros type qui est
tellement lot de conséquences
puisqu'elle est exactement scruter puis
la difficulté avec aplomb seul accès aux
cultures parce que c'est s'excuse de
tout et y ont essayé de te casser les
yankees millions il ya en vous fiant et
dans une certaine façon ça a marché
carrément un vrai pas de recul carrément
mais la difficulté en fait c'est cathy
lalbenque des dénonciations le prince
turki certaines des histoires d'horreur
cette histoire des histoires qui valait
la peine des histoires que je disais sur
ce jeu tht j'étais atterré il le dit je
n'achete pas croire que les humains qui
font ce document et le tpiy est il des
mêmes personnes ainsi que plusieurs jeux
gage d'une même personne d affaire
horrible je me dis crime si ça sert que
cette personne ne peut arrêter de faire
des victimes le genre all-in le go for
it
mais après ce trait sur tout le monde
s'entend l'histoire d'aurore
démonstrateur pour dire ça n'a pas de
bon sens faut que ça arrête
mais après ce milieu tout un arc en ciel
de pannes récurrentes en éventail sur
l'autre bout du spectre le sujet depuis
l'aube et le lui dit maudit un
commentaire déplacé en 2012 puis j'ai
pas aimé ce cancer c'est comme mes
autres saisons comme en salle je vous
dis à personne en télévision qui peut
traverser ce domaine mais pour le la
personne aurait un petit come & stay des
atrocités répétition versus il m'a dit
un commentaire déplacé en 2002 j'ai pris
mes ce hack export et une ligne t1 mais
est floue tpiy leader des fois c'est
jugé au même niveau d'égalité
quatre listes anonyme avec 2000 noms qui
ça va de viol à commentaires déplacés
sans aucune aucun agissement qui me avec
un nom ben c'est de mettre tout les noms
j'en même égalité
ici à côté là c'est peut-être fait ce
danger là c'était comme une zone grise
immense puis il ya peu un point où est
ce que dieu qui va partir d'exactement
l'eau il mérite d'être consolé mais en
dessous non ça se fait pas fac ça
devient une espèce de deux ans grisou
est ce que chacun ait le juge dit pili
plus les plus hardcore finalement vont
aller aux comptes mais tu es vont voir
les side cars en scellier des gens qui
étudient voyons donc lancé pour ce
métier genre des fois mes petits as
vraiment des sujets qui valent la peine
de six à vous la peine il ya des
comportements qu'ils sont non qui ne
sont pas acceptables seulement mais des
fois c'est comme ça soit pas il faut
trouver
le projet à vous qui pour ces rapports
qu'est-ce que tu viennes de l'excellent
point la conversation
peut-être trouve toi un projet peut-être
qui concerne toi le ton projet qui n'est
pas celui des autres
ton petit projet de son chéri ok il faut
qu'on se calme le pompon nouvelle enfin
quand il faut que le monde ce câble le
pompon là on est lol faut se calmer le
pompon
mais moi si j'ai tellement de la balle
mais je me suis heureux que mes patients
plein de tweets moins que chacun prêche
pas tout et ça j'aime être en europe
j'ai crible je veux l'écrire message
qu'on mangeait plus besoin de l'envoyer
dans son double face à mike ces accords
mets vins rouges fâché je veux l'écrire
mal formulé pleut je révise mon tout il
pleut jamais beau as exactement ce qui
me fâche au bosc avec le gip eu besoin
de les supprimer c'est ça c'est mon
exercice d'auto censure eu beaucoup
qu'est-ce qu'on nous appelle encore en
vie ah mon dieu je sais pas honnêtement
leur je ne le sais pas est ce qu'on ne
souhaite mettons le de rapidement sortir
dans un bond des amis la zone rouge et
des langues
non mais honnêtement je pense qu'est ce
qu'on peut vous souhaiter que c'est
vraiment plus fort
sur un plan personnel du transit ce
moment j'ai des trucs qui sont ma vie
personnelle pour une des rares fois
depuis longtemps et comme au prix la
priorité sur ma carrière
évidemment je je me souhaite toujours
des projets professionnels
j'ai envie des projets qui vont mais
c'est quand même la formule sur youtube
lé là comprennent fait longtemps que
j'ai pas sorti une vidéo jeux comme on
dit que je suis fier de moi genre j'ai
hâte d'avoir un projet comme ça qui me
dépasse un petit cache pas sorti c'est
comme cette petite feeling leur lectorat
ça sorte le monde le voit puis le
travail de tout le monde ça comme
amplifie ce qu on avait dantec tout le
monde cg je m'ennuie de stop ce je
l'avais dans le début de ma chaîne
youtube parce que le format était
nouveau à chaque nouvelle vidéo c'était
comment on découvre quelque chose et le
on voit le genre de job côté qu'un
trépied et puis bon fait le tour là
dessus c'est que je me souhaite des
projets
j'ai envie d'un projet que j'aimerais
tellement feu un projet zhang quelque
chose au chpo de serge daney d'être le
visage de mes affaires je tendais de
parler de moi la prison tant ses prêts
afin autre chose je retournerais tu
faire travailler votre académie qui me
dit j'ai fait tout le monde a dit oui et
non g j'ai perdu beaucoup d'illusions à
voir le monde de la télévision
mais le monde la télévision et pour
mieux qu'il était quand je l'aï quitté
c'est de plus en plus difficile on en
demande de plus en plus aux équipes
pendant fait de plus en plus avec de
moins en moins parce que le public
décroche cinquième monte de moins en
moins mais je pense que c'est de moins
en moins le fun
de mon point de vue d'extérieur fait que
le plaisir que j'ai eu à sport academy
ou sur d'autres projets comme pet pas
envie d'aller voir ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui mais peut-être qu'on m'avait
demandé de retravailler à star académie
cette année j'aurais probablement dit
oui
parce que je veux sortir de chine une
excuse de sortir j'ai l'impression qu'à
la télé on peut faire plein de choses
que la société ont pas le droit de faire
en ce moment
après comme le hongre games qui quand
ils vont dans le capitole yank l'un des
privilèges pas parce que c'est le grand
spectacle que le régime offre à la
population en famine
bon ben je pense ce sens notamment big
brother ils ont tous les privilèges
comme ça derrière nous pendant qu'on y
est en temps réel à la maison pendant
qu'on est en sécheresse sociale quand
même un peu effectivement d'autres
qu'est ce qu'on peut souhaiter à 30
heures combien de saisons
cent trente deux 32 53 2 c'est
incroyable je mène ma merci j'ai
vraiment excité de données voire j'avais
hâte de me revenir parce que c'est
vraiment classique et j'adore vos en
tant qu'homme guy gérard max à des
conversations en bourse en deux jours
dont vous écoutez j'ai l'année dernière
j'ai écouté votre salut adamou et son
collègue jérôme un accès des
conversations du côté rouennais de plus
j'ai enfin la fin et je trouve son corps
dans l'espace et je trouve que l'opinion
des quelques secondes et le sujet de
deux hommes blancs et eros si ce genre
et robin thicke de la façon que ça se
passe ici oui à vaincre et merci j'ai eu
l'impression d'un stand soirée où je
peux inviter d'habitude parce que j'ai
beaucoup d'amis j'ai beaucoup d'amis ici
que j'te contingent dans votre podcast
merci mr paypal à mes compliments
merci merci merci